WTF ist... oh.
So. Haha.
Irgendwie habe ich mich äh noch...
...habe ich es noch an.
So wunderbar.
Also.
Äh ich habe ein bisschen Audio-Settings rumgestellt.
Also es könnte sein, dass das jetzt irgendwie sich komisch anhört.
Sollte aber nicht.
Also.
Theoretisch sollte es sich besser anhören als vorher.
Sollte sich gleichmäßiger anhören als vorher.
Ich kann euch gleich mal zeigen, was ich eingestellt habe.
Vielleicht ist ja irgendwie der Audio-Pro am Start.
Der weiß, was ich da überhaupt gemacht habe.
Ah ja ja.
So. Und zwar.
Ich habe Sound-Settings eingestellt.
Weil das letzte Mal, der einem jemand erzählt...
Musik ist ein bisschen lauter.
Aber es ist ein bisschen...
...ein bisschen...
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ich mich anders an
Ähm, ich hab aber nix großartig drinnen
Also ich hab kein, ähm, ich hab kein Noiscade drinnen
Soll ich mal, ey wenn ich mal Noiscade anmache, soll ich jetzt richtig hängen geblieben an, wartet mal
Bist du krank, ne?
Ich hab, ich hab
einen Kompressor reingemacht
Das, ähm, ich mich gleichmäßiger anhör
Wenn ihr wollt, dass ich mich mal krank anhör, dann muss ich das hier anmachen, wartet mal
Das hier, da, da hör ich mich richtig krank anhör
Hahaha
Das riecht kaputt, wenn ich das hier anschalte, oder?
Das hört sich einfach kaputt an
Deswegen, das lass ich mal, das lass ich mal raus
Wir können, wir gucken mal, also
Es ist, es ist immer eine Sache
Oh, huge Musik
Ok, die Musik ist doch ein bisschen laut
So, und deswegen
Also ich hör mich jetzt, ich hör mich jetzt gleichmäßiger
Und ich habe mal eingebaut dass ich nicht mehr übersteuern kann das kam ja manchmal vor, wenn ich überwusten musste oder so
Dann habe ich übersteuert aber das greift eh erst hier vorne irgendwo ein also sprich ob ich das jetzt rein oder raus mache ist vollkommen egal
Moment sollte das nicht eigentlich bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
Man sollte überhaupt keinen Unterschied machen das sollte erst das sollte erst world save viewer dankeschön twitch prime huge sub
das sollte erst also achtung wenn ich jetzt wenn ich jetzt zu laut bin dann hört sich das so an
und wenn ich das hier rein mache dann kann ich gar nicht zu laut sein so so soweit von der theorie
Valorant Meinung ich finde ich habe es nicht ausprobiert ich weiß dass heute die Beta startet die Ubuntu Beta
ne die Valorant Beta startet auch lustigerweise aber auch die auch die auch die
Ubuntu Beta Pilzschema ist auch am start zwei Monate schon huge high IQ sub ich habe mein memebot noch gar nicht gestartet
es startet nicht starte das verdammte spiel ne wo ist es denn ich habe glaubt meine wie ging das
IP bin aus das IP konfig meine IP hat sich geändert ich habe jetzt auf einmal aus mir nicht näher ersichtlichen
gründen habe ich auf einmal die IP hier wow riesen riesen eier ja massive eier ja
so guckt ihr das oh ich habe das limitieren gar nicht mal an aber es geht trotzdem nicht
über minus fünf wahnsinn ja was auch immer ich da eingestellt habe ich weiß nicht genau aber ich
also ich sollte mich jetzt deutlich gleichmäßiger anhören als vorher das ist glaube ich ist glaube
ich angenehmer muss man mal gucken so jetzt müssen wir noch einmal schnell den das meme
bot steine das nicht das war tatsächlich für scheiß ihr wisst ihr wisst was ich meine das
chat auf zeichnen programm starten weil sonst über sehe ich mir da alles mögliche wen haben
wir hier noch am start das pilzschema die pilzschema hatten wir schon aber trotzdem hier zwei
monatlich huge sub und world saviour auch wahnsinnig high IQ subs heute wieder das endzone spiel scheint
wohl gut auf steam gestartet zu sein eier echtzeit strategie kann kann man eigentlich nie genug haben
so run so jetzt werden wir den kram erst einmal löschen die fragen vom letzten stream weil ich
glaube wir haben alles hatten alles vom letzten mal so gut so und chat jetzt refresh ich euch mal
kurz ich muss euch mal kurz refreshen weil ich sehe nicht wie viele leute da sind so perfekt
gut jetzt jetzt jetzt sollte alles passen also also leute wir müssen mal ein bisschen gucken was
audioeinstellungen angeht wenn ich irgendwie keine ahnung zu leise zu laut zu abgehakt zu
sonst was bin dann gucken wir ja muss man schauen als einzige was echt sagt ist da ich festgestellt
habe und das ist keinem bisher irgendwie aufgefallen ist das erst weil normalerweise höre ich mich ja
nicht nicht selbst also ich höre mich selbst allerdings nicht über den gleichen weg wie ihr
mich hört also ich hoffe ihr versteht was ich meine und deswegen ist mir nie aufgefallen dass
dieses komische audio interface was ich verwende für da wo das mikrofon für den stream reingeht
dass das übelst rauscht total beschissen dass das ist das übelste rauscher man start und das
ist mir nie aufgefallen weil ich höre mich ja über den zweiten weg der nicht rauscht also
das mikrofon rauscht nicht sondern das aufnehmen rauscht also vom von dem audio interface was
ich hier am gaming beziehungsweise spiele rechner dran ab das sagt so das hat aber noch keiner
gemerkt dass ich rauscht das heißt ich rausch jetzt auch aber ihr merkt anscheinend nicht dass ich
rausche chat muss noch mehr samm für mehr IQ dass man das rauschen irgendwann hört oder vielleicht
vielleicht ist ja mittlerweile auch so dass man nicht nur IQ steigern kann sondern auch hören
durch subs vielleicht hört man an das rauschen irgendwann auch zumindest ich habe das beim
probehören festgestellt es rauscht das hat ziemlich gesagt so was macht ein unity media
leute null frames tropft null wahnsinn oder ist massive ich glaube die musik mal was ein
ticken leiser so sehr gut und ich habe mich ich habe mich schon ein bisschen leiser gemacht hier
sagt man geht die musik irgendwie ein bisschen vom audio in das mikro rein weil ich habe das
gefühl wenn die musik hier an ist dann höre ich die musik über wartet man das muss man checken
ok wir sind ja bei minus 35 gerade das kann man das kann man ganz einfach checken wir machen
die musik aus das ist mein gerausche das ist mein gerausche das ist mein gerausche wie gesagt
ich sage das audio interface rauscht aber irgendwie hat es auch keiner gemerkt ist auch nicht warum
aber aber eins müsste sagen ich bin ich bin schon gleichmäßiger jetzt oder also vom sound her
bin ich gleich gleichmäßiger wobei ich ich sollte eigentlich nicht ins rote gehen das ist schlecht
kannst du deinen boomer messenger tweet noch noch weiter ausführen kann ich machen was willst du
wissen vielleicht können wir einfach auch den output gain noch ein bisschen runter machen weil
ich bin ganz schön laut jetzt bin aber zu leise ne 10er 10er output das war schon decibel ist
eine richtige scheißeinheit habe ich dir schon mal gesagt wer sich die das ist das ist so das ist das
dreimal mehr ist doppelt so laut und solche komischen dinge näher ist es ja nicht ganz aber
so merkwürdig irgendwie so ich glaube ich glaube mit zehn war ein bisschen laut oder ich mache
noch mal kurz zehn so zehn ist ein bisschen laut oder so hier weil wenn ich da jetzt mal
irgendwie ein bisschen lauter huste dann dann wird schon wird schon ein bisschen laut
also soll ich so lassen soll ich soll ich auf zehn stellen oder soll ich soll ich lieber
auf sieben stellen von der lautstärke her so so oder so zehn ist top ok im prinzip also was
jetzt natürlich richtiger fail ist was mir jetzt gerade auffällt ist wenn ich schreie passiert auch
nicht viel also es sollte das da muss ich das ding hier an machen es sollte eigentlich gut
funktionieren es sollte eigentlich gut funktionieren also sprich selbst wenn ich jetzt ultra laut rede
dann dann geht das nicht auf null das sollte das sollte der kompressor eigentlich halbwegs
händeln hört sich zwar der kacke an aber das sollte nicht überschreiten also nicht doch
es kann schon überschreiten aber es sollten euch nicht die oren rausfallen so wir lassen
wir wissen was wir lassen es einfach so genug rumgespielt kommen wir jetzt mal
aktuell jubantu an jubantu jubantu ja ja was auch immer also es hat mich ja irgendjemand
gerade gefragt was ich zu wähler rennt oder wie spricht man das eigentlich aus
wähler rennt wie auch immer wähler rennt wähler von mut und so und mutig oder so ich kann kein
schimmer wie hast du eigentlich den follow alert das ist die labs das ist einfach einfach
eins zu eins fertig so da kann man einfach das kann man einfach anklicken und dann dann sieht
so aus ist es bei euch auch so oder ist mein ohr kaputt bin ich bin ich links ein bisschen
bisschen lauter als rechts ne oder ich glaube mal ich glaube mein mein mein ohr spackt glaub
da ist kein unterschied ja also ich wie gesagt ich habe dazu noch keine mir noch keine wahnsinnig
wahnsinnige meinung gebildet weil dann mich ist mono das geht nicht das stimmt richtig wobei
richtige hexa können auch mono mix links und rechts unter also ich kann ich kann jetzt ja
splitten ich kann einfach aus einem mono zwei audiospuren machen und die eine leiser machen
das ist zwar nicht das liegt da zwar nicht am mikrofon das wäre dann kann ich nichts kann
ich nichts zu sagen zu wähler rennt was ich ich also was ich bisher gesehen habe was also
eine sache finde ich da ganz gut dran und zwar dass man wohl gesagt hat man man will weniger
auf erwacht sein mehr cs oder muss ich sagen das finde ich prinzipiell gut weil mir persönlich
ist ja ein auf erwacht auch am ende auf den keks gegangen das auf erwacht so viel auf erwacht
mal es ist weiß ich ob man mir jetzt geistig folgen konnte klang klang jetzt wir ja ich weiß aber
am anfang war auf erwacht für mich in den game wo man sagen kann ja es wurden also die helden die
wo man halt auch shooter spielen können musste die waren auch gut konnte man mit mccree gut
abgehen mit soldier gut abgehen teilweise es war nicht so dieses dieses melees dann hemmermeter
was danach gekommen ist ich weiß nicht wie es jetzt aussieht und es fand ich halt doof dass
ich auf erwacht schon die richtung entwickelt hat dass so viel so viel nicht shooter charaktere
am start war und das scheint er nicht zu sein also sprich die wollen wohl mehr cs sein
als auf erwacht und das finde ich gut mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen aber es ist nicht gerade die
beta gestartet wo kann man eigentlich die beta den beta beta download hier download da
moment mal so wir wollen wir wollen nämlich einmal wir wollen einmal das desktop image
und einmal wollen wir den server installer wir wollen nicht beides mal probieren weil
sie haben angeblich viel am server installer gemacht jede woche eine andere meta ja das finde
ich gut dass das brauche auf das hat auf erwacht ich gebrauchte vor allem halt in kombination mit
das blizzard früher zumindest ich weiß das mittlerweile besser ist früher gefühlt halt
so gepatcht hat dass du ein halbes jahr lang die gleichen meta kack spielen musstest das hat
halt keinem so richtig gefallen so aber jetzt ich müsste mich doch im großen und ganzen anhören
wie sonst oder bloß bloß halt bloß halt ein bisschen gleichmäßiger weil wenn ich mich richtig
beschissen anhören soll dann würde ich das hier anmachen und das hört sich nämlich richtig
beknackt an wenn ich wenn ich wenn ich neues wenn ich neue suppression anmache wenn ich
wenn ich neue suppression ausmachen aber das klingt richtig scheiße das klingt richtig
geblieben lull hoch wow monkaS was ist jetzt los
oder von oder oder doch nehmen wir starten den dauerner einfach neu
fack leute ich weiß was ich zeige euch jetzt mal was wir machen jetzt wir machen jetzt big
brain download magic zwar wir gehen jetzt hier auf unsere ledungs vm ich kopiere mal die url
wo ist die url hier zum desktop image lautstärke passt ich kopiere mal die url zum desktop image
und jetzt haben wir hier den da der lebt nämlich mit mehreren mit mehreren dings hier gleichzeitig
runter easy kuck und schon sind wir bei 49 sekunden eats easy das sind schon immer 34
sekunden fertig der macht einfach glaub die folgt mäßig keine ahnung 12 verbindungen
oder so auf poggers der michael 50 billionen ist wieder am start ja ja irgendjemand hat
gefragt was ans fs so gut ist wenn ich mal kurz was zu sagen während der kram runter
led runter led geht ab linux ich glaube die haben ganz gute übersicht ansonsten kann ich
meine erfahrung berichten nur weil nur ich will mir zu meiner seite angucken dass ich
kein bullshit erzählen und die hälfte vergesse anscheinend haben die keine schöne übersicht
also was was hat zfs im vergleich zu normalen fallsystem für für vorteile wir fangen wir
fangen erst mal an mit den nachteilen würde ich sagen zfs ist relativ komplex ja also
sprich zfs hat 30 milliarden stellschrauben und du kannst gott und die welt einstellen
und bis vor kurzem konnte man auch im zfs nicht erweitern ich glaube da sind sie gerade
dran und vielleicht ist es im aktuellen release schon drin weiß ich nicht muss man mal gucken
man konnte den zfs pool lange zeit nicht erweitern es sei denn also den zfs rate es sei denn
man hat quasi das gleiche noch mal reingesteckt also sprich man hat in den pool oder in den
rate aus irgendwie drei platten und da musste man dann noch mal drei platten dazu machen
und das spiegeln dann kommt man das erweitern aber das war nicht schön also zfs war in der
verwaltung her in allem bisschen ein bisschen over the top aber sie sind wirklich gut dabei
das ganze anzupassen guck mal kopieren ist fertig so und dann noch ein noch ein weiterer
nachteil von zfs ist im vergleich zu normalen normalen fallsystem so was wie x4 oder xfs
oder solche dinger dass das viel ram verbraucht also es wird empfohlen dass dass man zfs quasi
stand ab ich glaube standardmäßig ratio ist eingestellt die hälfte des rams ich
bin mir nicht ganz sicher zumindest möchte zfs sehr viel ram haben man muss aber dazu
sagen dass da kursierend also da kursieren im internet viele merkwürdige guides so nach
dem motto unter 48 gigabyte sollte man kein zfs einsetzen das ist kompletter blödsinn
ja du kannst einfach mit gestinkt normalen 8g oder 4g einsetzen das muss ich halt nur
gucken dass man sich dadurch auch ein paar einbußen holt wenn man halt viele user und
parallele zugriffe hat was man ja wenn man daheim sein sein sein sein sein fall sauber
hat den vielleicht zwei drei leute verwenden gar nicht hat dann gibt es noch eine weitere
sache dass man nach möglichkeit ecc ram verwenden soll für zfs ist aber auch nicht so ganz
richtig wenn man halt die stärken von zfs wirklich noch weiter ausbauen will dann sollte
man vielleicht dann sollte man ecc ram nehmen aber es ist nicht so dass zfs irgendwie schlechter
wird ohne ecc ram also wenn man es vergleicht mit einem normalen fallsystem wo du beispielsweise
fehler nicht nicht rechtzeitig feststellen oder wo fehler überhaupt passieren können
dann treten in zfs nicht auf einmal fehler auf nur weil man keinen ecc ram hat so und
auch auch ein giga genau das gibt es auch das gibt es auch oft so ein gigabyte ram pro
terabyte und so was in der richtung kann man alles machen wobei sich das halt das empfehlungen
sind wenn man das wirklich auch unterordentlich last mit vielen leuten und parallelen zugriffen
betreiben will daheim kommt man auch ohne probleme mit einer ziemlich schwachbrüstigen
kiste und zfs aus dann hat man zwar nicht die wahnsinn performance und ist wahrscheinlich
sogar einen ticken langsamer rein was io angeht und zugriffszeiten angeht wie wenn man das
jetzt klassisch macht mit einer ssd und einfach xfs drauf oder x4 drauf aber jetzt kommen
wir zu den vorteilen zfs hat auch eine hat auch jede menge vorteile ich suche man nebenbei
eine liste nicht dass ich die helfe oder vergesse das erste was für mich sehr praktisch ist
ist dass alles eingebaut ist in zfs rate ist eingebaut so mal ob sie ordentlich oder was
heißt ein vorteil auf englisch leute ich stehe gerade auf dem schlauch features features
oder so mal wieso nach features wieso nach features features ist glaube ich in dem fall
besser in dem features wie kommt man zu features so aber erst mal meine eindrücke zu zu zfs
also eins was für mich ein riesen vorteil ist es ist in zfs alles eingebaut du hast
ich kriege immer anfälle wenn die leute auf youtube videos leute mit du anreden ich zeige
dir heute wie du deine fritzbox einrichtest als erstes musst du sicherstellen dass die
fritzbox am netzwerk angeschlossen ist da kriege ich komplett ausschlag wenn ich die
leute immer so man sagt man sagt ihr man redet nicht mit einem man selbst ist einer und redet
mit keine ahnung hunderten tausend und zehntausend was auch immer ich mag das nicht wenn die
leute direkt angeredet werden in den videos so und bei zfs ist halt alles dabei sprich
verschlüsselung ist eingebaut rate ist eingebaut snapshots sind eingebaut also alles was man
irgendwie braucht ist eingebaut unterstützung für file sharing ist eingebaut also sowas
wie samba und sowas auch wenn es unter linux standen standard zeug verwendet nfs ist eingebaut
es ist quasi alles standardmäßig drinnen was man was man irgendwie so braucht das ist
riesen vorteil von zfs dann hat dann hat es noch jede menge weitere sachen die wie gesagt
die snapshot geschichte anderes neues mikro hört man das 1436 roffel also ich habe nicht
wirklich ich habe ich habe kein anderes mikro ich habe ich habe mal den kompressor eingeschaltet
dass ich jetzt ungefähr einheitlich dass ich jetzt ungefähr hört sich besser an hört
sich besser dass ich einheitlicher bin dass ich mich einheitlicher anhöre sehr viel besser
excellent excellent exquisite können gleich richtig los hexen genau so dann geht es weiter
was was auch noch tolle sache ist an zfs dass man snapshots machen kann also sprich wenn
ich jetzt ein paket update installiere mal kernel update mal außen vor da ist die integration
auch nicht so schön dass man da so hin und zurück und sonst wie rollen kann aber sagen
wir mal ich mache ein paket update oder ich mache ein update wo jetzt nicht grad kernel
dabei ist vielleicht installiere ich auch eine neue docker version oder irgendwas ich
installiere eine neue version von irgendwas vollkommen egal und da mache ich vorhin ein
snapshot und dann kann ich relativ einfach den kram zurückrollen on a fly das ist eine
super geschichte und zfs snapshots kosten auch keinen speicherplatz zfs snapshots kannst
du tausende anlegen die kosten alle keinen speicherplatz die fangen erst an speicherplatz
zu kosten wenn das delta zwischen ursprünglichem zeitpunkt und snapshot also was geschrieben
wurde sehr groß wird dann fangen snapper also du kannst von du kannst mit zfs 300 snapshots
machen die kosten alle keinen speicherplatz die kosten erst speicherplatz umso älter
sie werden umso mehr passiert umso mehr zwischen dem snapshot zeitpunkt und jetzt halt passiert
es deswegen ist es eine super geschichte wenn ich ein wenn ich ein großes upgrade mache
oder mal angenommen ich habe ich habe einen server wo ich noch so old school bin und da
irgendwie mehrere kunden drauf hab und die sind nicht in containern und sonst was da
mache ich einfach snapshot snapshot snapshot snapshot und löscht die einfach der reihen
nach wieder aber ich habe erst mal unmittelbar die sicherheit dass ich einfach wieder zurückrollen
kann geht das auch auf ein oboto 1604 da bin ich mir nicht sicher ob 1604 schon schon
zfs dabei hat also 1804 hat auf jeden fall zfs dabei aber 1604 bin ich mir nicht sicher
also anscheinend nicht offiziell naja aber 1604 ist es ist es doch eh dieses jahr end
of life oder und ich hab nix gesagt leute fuck läuft das lang alter der scheiß läuft
ja lang durch das man es ist sogar 1404 ist noch support bis 2002 wahnsinn und das alles
umsonst kann man sich echt nicht nicht beschweren bei den jubantu hexorn so dann noch ein riesen
vorteil von zfs im vergleich zu den meisten anderen datalysystem ist dass dir nicht einfach
so ich muss da ein bisschen zurück also die aussage ist die ist nicht so schlimm wie
es sich jetzt anhört also es ist nicht so dass wenn du andere fallsysteme verwendest
dass dein zeug kaputt geht oder so das ist dass ich schwachsinn aber es kann kaputt gehen
ohne dass du es mitbekommst also wenn es deine festplatte irgendein fehler hat und ein paar
sektoren sind kaputt und dadurch vielleicht ein paar dateien beschädigt dann kriegt es
normales fallsystem nicht so ohne weiteres mit das kriegt es dann erst mit wenn und falls
es im check macht wenn du glück hast und wenn du glück hast kann es auch recover bei
zfs ist das kein problem zfs hat für alles checksum und kriegt alles mit also sprich
zfs geht eher kaputt bevor deine dateien kaputt gehen oder besser gesagt zfs geht eher read
only bevor deine dateien kaputt gehen also was sagen die selbst noch für vorteile weil
ich vergesse wahrscheinlich wieder die hälfte genau checksum das ist das was ich gerade
erklärte copy und write das ist das was ich meinte das erst mal initial nicht speicher
braucht erst wenn es abweicht snapshots hatten wir auch schon pool data storage ja man kann
man kann jede menge die musik ist laut oder oder ne passt dafür bin ich ja gleichmäßig
lauter bin ich eigentlich der einzige in dem das super mario theme nicht gefällt ich komme
mir da immer wieder übelste game musik banause vor aber ich mag das super mario theme überhaupt
nicht man kann total abgedrehte sachen machen mit volumes und und data sets und gedöns
also man kann das sehr schön kopieren und und managen das ganze zfs hat auch extrem
viele tuning optionen was man machen kann lautstärke passt also von kompression bis
die duplication da ist alles möglich wobei man diese sachen mit vor sich genießen muss
gerade die duplication braucht wirklich enorm viel ram kompression kann man eigentlich auf
aktuellen cpus bedenkenlos einschalten dann ist ganze rate geschichte mit eingebaut das heißt
man braucht auch kein irgendwie md rate kein lux und gedöns man kann quasi rate und encryption
jetzt alles in einem machen so genau das ist auch das ist auch eine coole geschichte man
kann eine ssd als cash verwenden also sprich wenn man wenn man irgendwie einen rate 5 hat
oder rate 10 oder irgendwas mit oder rate 6 mit vielen vielen platten drinnen und das
ist nicht das allerschnellste ist dann kann man dafür sorgen dass das erst mal gecasht
wird auf eine ssd und dann weggeschrieben die haben terminologie die ich bis heute nicht
ganz gecheckt haben was da was ist schaust du immer auf deine verbrauchte leistung auf
dein pc nö du weißt stromverbrauch nö an dem normalen pc habe ich gar nichts angeschlossen
wo ich was angeschlossen habe ist hier an der an der kiste hinter mir so genau man kann
extrem viel speicher kann extrem viel speicherplatz im zfs allerdings muss man sagen ich mir
mir fällt kein anwendungszweck ein wo ich mal an das speicher limit von xfs und x4 gestoßen
wäre ich weiß gar nicht wo das liegt also zumindest kann zfs 256 quadrillionen zeta
beitsch nee oder zeta beitsch speichern was auch immer das ist
keine ahnung es ist viel ja aber so viel ist ist wurscht ich glaube man ist gesehen dass
das hat seine daseinsberechtigung vielleicht jetzt nicht auf so einer normalen auf normalen
desktop wobei es da auch seine vorteile haben kann aber es ist auf jeden fall eine coole
sache hast du etwas zu dem thema studiert nee sondern was zu zfs studieren ich habe
mich damit halt notgedrungenermaßen beschäftigt weil ich auch am aktuellen software zfs laufen
habe also auf der meinem heimding was hier hinter mir steht was mir aber im nachhinein
zu overkill gewesen ist ich hatte dreimal 10 terabyte drinne davon ist im prinzip noch
fast alles frei so also installen probieren wir mal aus mit was von mal anfangen im server
installer oder dem desktop installer wir gucken uns erstmal den desktop installer an weil
er ist angeblich auch viel besser das ganze erstellen wir unter e doppelpunkt forms
habe ich habe ich bin ich doof gewesen ich kann ich habe da keine unterverzeichnungs
gemacht ich habe direkt da reingeschrieben auch sehr sehr clever max big brain meine
verzeichnungsstruktur dann machen wir jetzt dann machen wir weiter weiter weiteres big
brain passt mal auf so sehr gut so muss das sein 4 cpus 16 g ram 16 mb 16 g ach das geht
da ja nicht 16 g ram weil es geht nicht weil man es braucht einfach weil es funktioniert
60 gigabyte speichert er nicht da e doppelpunkt vms 2 da sollste speichern und ich bei mir
auf der platte so den trucker schmeißen wir raus den trucker schmeißen wir immer raus
wir haben unsere
ver describte
Durch was viel billigeres, viel kleineres, viel stromsparendes, allerdings auch viel leistungsschwächeres
Aber das war einfach komplett overkill, was ich mir da zusammen gebastelt habe
Ich meine, das ist keine Kiste, die bei uns im Rechenzentrum steht, das ist was für mich daheim
Ich habe viel mehr Leistung da rein gebaut, weil ich total übertrieben habe, wie
Wie ich eigentlich gebraucht hätte So, jetzt wollen wir mal chat gucken, ich habe ein paar Sachen übersehen
Was hältst du von QLC SSDs? Kann ich nicht viel zu sagen, zumindest nicht qualifiziert
Was? Disks? Welche Disks willst du bitteschön checken?
Da ist überhaupt keine Disks drin, außer die leere, die leere Disk ist drin
Ok, dann checke mal leere Disks, ok
Big Prane Ubuntu Hättest du den zum Rechenzentrum gebracht?
Er schreckt mich nicht so
Er schreckt mich nicht so Ubuntu, was soll das?
Get schrecked
So, Englisch, Install, Keyboard layout, nee nee nee nee, German, German, no, Deadkey, das brauchen wir, continue
Continue
Ok, also das ist jetzt anscheinend neu, ich habe schon ehrlich gesagt so Hand aufs Herz, ja
Wie das der Kabum früher immer schon gesagt hat
Ich habe schon lange kein Ubuntu Desktop mehr installiert
Oh, ich noob, ich habe die Stream vor allem ausgeschaltet
Nein, der Chatlogger funktioniert ja sonst nicht mehr
WTF, das geht ja nicht, 570 IQ
Der Basti schreibt, es gab mal ein Berechen, dass mit aktuellen HDDs die Menge an Speicherplatz, die komplette Menge, alles Wasser auf der Erde benötigen würde zur Kühlung
Aha
Also wir sind in Deutschland, normalerweise berechnen wir Sachen in Fußballfeldern, da können wir uns irgendwie besser vorstellen
So, ich muss mal kurz den Chat durchscrollen, wenn ich irgendwas übersehen habe
Irgendwas sollte ich vorher näher ausführen, ein Boomer-Tweet hat jemand geschrieben, ja
Ich habe mal eine Frage, vielleicht hast du oder der Chat eine Lösung, und zwar muss ich irgendwie Internet übers LAN, also schreibt der Meister proper
Internet übers LAN von einem Raum über zwei andere Räume zu meinem Büro bringen
Findest du, dass das Powerline eine gute Lösung ist?
Das kommt aufs Haus an, ob Powerline eine gute Lösung ist
Aber zeichne mal her, du willst irgendwie, was, zwar muss ich Internet übers LAN von einem Raum über zwei andere Räume, warum nicht einfach WLAN?
Also so schlecht, wenn du nicht spielen willst, ist WLAN nur wirklich nicht übel
Und selbst mal spielen, WLAN ist an sich eh besser als sein Ruf
Powerline ist auf jeden Fall eine Option, wenn das gut funktioniert, bei dir kommt ein bisschen aufs Haus an
Ansonsten gibt es ja nicht viel Varianten, was willst du großartig machen?
Powerline, WLAN, du wirst dir weder eine Mikrowelle, noch Richtfunk, noch eine Glasfaserleitung irgendwie in der Straße mieten wollen, keine Ahnung
Es gibt ja ansonsten viele Varianten, was du machen kannst
So, ich glaube ich habe nichts mehr übersehen soweit
Was hältst du von USB-Sticks, die sich als Datentresor ausgeben mit FIPS-Verschlüssel und ETC?
Da gibt es ein paar gute Sachen, ich habe einen...
Fuck, wie hieß das Ding?
Ubiqui hieß das, genau
Der liegt hier irgendwo rum
Und legt vor sich hin
Habe ich noch nicht benutzt, aber die soll ganz gut sein
Schon mal einen Hackintosh installiert, ich habe es probiert auf einer ganz alten Kiste, die liegt hier übrigens immer noch unter dem Tisch
Und da hatte Mac Probleme mit der integrierten Grafikkarte und seither habe ich nie wieder angefasst
Ja, also wie gesagt, zu der Router-Thematik
Ich würde gucken, ob ich das nicht mit WLAN machen kann
WLAN ist okay, man kann gegen WLAN eigentlich nicht viel sagen
Es muss ja, also wenn du Probleme hast
Oder dich stört, WLAN-Sticks oder WLAN an den Rechnern zu verwenden
Du kannst natürlich auch einfach WLAN-Access-Point hinstellen
Und dort dann einen Switch anschließen
Und an den Switch dann per Kabel die Rechner, das funktioniert auch
Oder du kaufst dir halt eine ordentliche...
Wie nennt man das?
So eine ordentliche Funkbrücke oder so
Wie heißt denn das?
Irgend so ein Richtfunk-Ding
Aber das braucht man dafür gar nicht, wenn das einfach nur zwei Räume weiter ist
Wenn das nur zwei Räume weiter ist, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich genau so machen
Ich würde es über WLAN machen, ich würde mir einen guten Access-Point holen
Auf der anderen Seite auch ein ordentliches Endgerät hinstellen
Daran kommt wieder ein Switch und daran kommen die Endgeräte, fertig
Dann braucht ihr nicht jedes Endgerät ein WLAN-Stick
Man kann die Endgeräte weiterhin per Kabel anschließen, aber an sich geht es über WLAN
So, machen wir weiter, Normalinstall und Minimalinstallation
Wir gucken uns mal die Normalinstallation
Download Updates While Installing
Perfekt
Moment, wir müssen für die passende Ubuntu Experience brauchen wir hier das hier
Gleich besser, oder?
Gleich viel angenehmer
Oder? So, muss das sein
Download Updates, Blah, ja, installieren, alles installieren, Next
Ja
Next
Berlin sind wir, passt
Your name, cute
Nee, Moment
Aja ja, muss ich aufpassen
Leute, ich habe, ich habe Deutsch
Ist das auch verbackt im Installer?
Ich habe deutsche, deutsche Tastatur layout
Chiller, Killer, eins, zwei, drei, vier
Bevor ich dir das erzähle, was ich für ein Mikrofon verwende
Hast du meinen Stream vorher schon mal geguckt?
Weil, dann würde ich gerne von dir wissen, ob du
Soundtechnisch einen Unterschied hörst zwischen heute und dem letzten Mal
Oh, ich installiere mit XFS, fuck
Ah
Siehste, Chat, ich habe nicht aufgepasst
Neustart
Weg
RIP
Ah, nochmal, wir haben ja noch nichts gemacht
Wir haben ja noch nichts gemacht
Ach
Ja, ich weiß, die Installation ist kaputt
Oh, nicht schnell genug
Jetzt, die Quickscope Reflexe, Leute, bam
Fuck
Ich weiß, dass es anders geht
Aber ich probiere das immer so, bis es klappt
Ich weiß, dass es anders funktioniert
Ah, yes, excellent
Ähm
So, CD
Englisch
Sind deine Wifi-USB-Powerschalter schon angekommen?
Äh, welche waren das noch?
Also, nee, sie sind nicht angekommen, aber ich überlege gerade, welche das waren
Ach, die
Die ich letztens im Video gezeigt habe, wo man
Geräte, USB-Geräte übers WLAN ein- und ausschalten kann
Die sind noch nicht angekommen
Aber die haben auch gesagt, ich glaube, Lieferzeitpunkt
Ich meine, es ist aus China
Die haben gerade andere Probleme, als mir USB-Geräte zu liefern, glaube ich
Ähm, aber die hatten auch, die hatten auch Lieferzeitpunkt, irgendwie 26.04. oder sowas
Nee, hast du nicht gesehen?
Also, ich habe ein MMX300 und das ganz normale Headset-Mikrofon, was da dran ist
Ein Biodynamics MMX300 Headset
Ich habe hier neben mir noch ein Ploieti-Mikrofon stehen
Und das ist ein Ploieti-Mikrofon
Aber ich finde es angenehmer, das über das Headset-Mikro zu machen
Vor der Qualität her, wäre das Ploieti besser
Und ich habe sogar noch im Schrank irgendwo
Damals, ich hatte mir ein recht teures Mikrofon für Voice-Aufnahme für Videos damals gekauft
Damals, ich hatte mir ein recht teuren Mikrofon für Voice-Aufnahme für Videos damals gekauft
gekauft. Das war mir dann aber im Handling auch zu anstrengend. So, ähm, Englisch. So,
jetzt gucken wir, ob jetzt die deutsche Tastatur funktioniert. German. No dead keys. So, wo
kann ich denn jetzt überhaupt ZFS im Installer auswählen? Wo kann man jetzt im Installer das
überhaupt auswählen? Wahrscheinlich danach, wenn es ums Partitionieren geht. Schauen wir mal.
Beste Musik. Hier vielleicht, Advanced Features. Ah, Erase Disk and Use ZFS. Was ist das hier?
Ne, da kann ich, da kann ich es von Hand machen. Hier, das da. Was, Something Else? Warum? Warum
sollte ich Something Else machen? Ich will ja mal gucken, wie der, dass ich es von Hand einrichten
kann, dachte ich mir, aber wir machen einfach mal das. Ich will mal gucken, was der macht,
wenn man es automatisch auswählt. Weil das werden ja auch die meisten Noobs machen.
Install Now. Okay, also was machen, was legt der an? Ähm, ist ne Boot Partition nämlich
mal an. Swap. Bpool, Airpool. Ist das, ist das für Boot? Macht der für Boot? Ne, einen
eigenes, einen eigenen Pool? Gucken wir uns danach an, wenn installiert ist. Ich kann euch
aber gleich sagen, ich bin mit ZFS ein bisschen eingerostet, was die Administration angeht,
weil auf der Arbeit verwenden wir kein ZFS mehr und meine Kiste hier hinten mit ZFS mit
den, mit den 3x10 Teraplatten, war ich schon fast ein Jahr nicht mehr eingeloggt, hab was
großartig drauf gemacht, aber so die Basics krieg ich noch zusammen. Abstürzen macht
er. Ich hab mit Ubuntu wenig Schmerzen gehabt, im Serverbetrieb wohlgemerkt, Desktop verwende
ich ja nicht. Okay, ähm, was war hier? Cute Chat. Passwort 123456, 123456. Yes, excellent.
Okay, gucken wir da im Ganzen mal zu. Nenn den Account CuteBoot. Machen wir beim nächsten
installieren. Machen wir beim nächsten installieren. Ähm, ja, mein Freund hat geschrieben, ich
soll meinen Boomer-Tweet von heute noch etwas genauer ausführen. Da muss ich erstmal überlegen,
was ich da geschrieben hab. Ach, die Leute. Ja, und zwar, wir haben auf der Arbeit Leute,
wir müssen ja alle zwangsläufig Homeoffice arbeiten jetzt. Gibt's ja, gibt's ja nix
mehr vor Ort. Ähm, und es tun sich, ich hab mich ja schon letztens drüber ausgelassen
im Stream, dass die wahre Elite quasi MMO-Spieler sind. Die wissen einfach, wie man online sinnvoll
mit Leuten kommuniziert. Die restlichen Leute sind zwar ziemlich, ziemlich Karknoobs, aber
es gibt eine Gruppe von Leuten, da ist es besonders schlimm. Und zwar die, nicht unbedingt
zu den, nicht rein die Boomer-Generationen. Da sind, da sind bei weitem auch davon nicht
alle und auch nicht nur um im Umkehrschluss, sondern die Leute, die Instant Messenger so
schreiben und so verwenden wie E-Mail. Heute, ich, ich kann mir das nicht merken, ich muss
es mal selbst zitieren von meinem Twitter. Ich muss es mal, ich muss mal zitieren von
meinem Twitter. Und zwar, ähm, hier. Guten Morgen, Kollegen. Wir sehen zurzeit einen Anstieg
von Fehlern im Load Balancer. Bitte leiten Sie Entstörungsmaßnahmen ein. Mit freundlichen
Grüßen, Kollege XY. Warum schreibt man so im Instant Messenger? Was ist, was, was ist
mit den Leuten los? Ja, und, ja, was gibt's da großartig noch zu erzählen, was soll,
was ich noch weiter ausführen soll? Das gibt da, es gibt da viel zu viele von. Normalerweise.
Also, ich hab mich ja letztens im Stream immer ausgelassen, dass ja, dass ja in Wirklichkeit,
was Home Office angeht und, ähm, Leute, die halt gut online, Remod mit anderen zusammenarbeiten
können, dass die neue Elite quasi MMO-Progress-Spieler ist bzw. Competitive-Spieler, Team-Competitive-Spieler
sind, die eben gelernt haben, wie man gut und, und, und, ähm, empathisch, nennen wir's
mal, online kommuniziert. Ich weiß, das klingt jetzt weit hergeholt zu dem ganzen Geflame,
das abgeht in Online-Games, aber wir reden ja hier von Leuten, die in einem festen Team
lange zusammenspielen können. Also, die müssen schon einen gewissen, gewissen Social-, Online-Social-Skill
haben, dass das funktioniert, sonst würden sie ja laufen, überall gekickt werden, ja.
Ich red' jetzt nicht von den Leuten in einem random Game, die sagen, alter, piss dich,
kack, ich fick deine Mutter. Ja, die, die mein ich nicht. Und die Leute sind das, die
im Home Office richtig gut arbeiten können und mit denen man auch richtig gut kommunizieren
kann. Und, ähm, da sind auch nicht die, die irgendwie schreiben, äh, hallo, Kollegen der
Load-Palencer, bla, bla, bla, mit freundlichen Grüßen, sondern die schreiben in Instant-Messenger
einfach so, wie sie in einem MMO schreiben würden, wenn sie eine Raidgruppe suchen. Halt
halt nicht Raidgruppe, sondern halt was zur Technik. Und wenn du in einem Messenger auf,
im Home Office zwei Leute hast, die MMOs irgendwie auf, auf, auf Progress mit Raiden und sonst
was gespielt haben, dann reden die im Home Office miteinander über den Chat ungefähr
so, wie wenn sie eine Raidgruppe suchen in einem MMO. Also sprich, einfach so, dass was
versteht. Funktioniert wunderbar. Und ich merk's immer wieder bei den Leuten, die keine
Erfahrung mit Online-Spielen haben, die kacken voll ab im Home Office, was Kommunikation
angeht. So, jetzt müssen wir erstmal schauen, ob die vielleicht es mittlerweile geschafft
haben. Das ist ja eine Sache, die geht mir bei Ubuntu schon seit zig Versionen auf den
Sack. Ähm, ob die's... Ah, sie haben's geschafft, Leute. Endlich! Sie haben's geschafft,
Forever Tools einzubauen. Endlich! Da warte ich ja schon ewig drauf. Ansonsten muss man
immer Forever Tools installieren. Und es hat dann rumgespackt. Das hier kann man übrigens
nicht verschieben. Sie haben's geschafft, Forever Tools zu installieren. Connect your
Online-Accounts. Nope. Skip. Live-Patch. Setup-Live-Patch. Was ist das? Was ist das? Ähm, probieren wir jetzt
mal aus. Ähm, also im Chat schreibt iBeyndle. Ähm, also ich habe das jetzt mal ausgerechnet.
Nehmen wir 10TB Low Profile 3,5 Zoll HDDs, dann brauchen wir... Alter, was ist das für
ne Zahl? 364.098,7 Fußballfelder nach den Abmaßen der Bundesliga um eine Max-Size-ZFS-Pool
zu speichern. Ah, excellent! Quickmuffs. Du hast dir eine Rolle Klopapier verdient. Für
so viel Intelligenz und Big-Brain-High-IQ im Chat. Nicht schlecht. Also wir brauchen ganz
schön viele Fußballfelder. So, Live-Patch. Was ist Live-Patch? Genug Klop... Was? Warum?
Ach. Ah. Live-Patch. Ich bin ja auch ein Kackknub. Live-Patch ist nicht, dass der automatisch
Updates installiert. Live-Patch ist diese Geschichte, dass du manche Kernel-Updates
und sonstige Sachen ohne Reboot machen kannst. Stimmt, da war was. Sowas haben die gehabt.
Brauchen wir nicht. Help Imp... Nein, wir wollen Ubuntu. Ubuntu nicht. Oder einfach
auch Ubuntu. Brauchen wir nicht. Improven. Location Service. Mal gucken, was passiert.
You can... Here you go. Okay. Das kann man nicht anklicken. Das ist Fake, Fake, Fake-Klicker.
Fake-Klicker ist das hier. Oder auch nicht. Wow. What the fuck. Wow. Oh. Ich hab's kaputt
gemacht, glaub ich. Also doch. Hat nur gedauert. Install. Also man muss sagen, die Oberfläche
sieht mittlerweile wirklich recht polished aus. Ich bin nach wie vor kein Fan von dem
Ubuntu-Farbschema. Hat mir seit der ersten Version nicht gefallen. Die ersten Version
war noch mehr braun anstatt dieses komische Lila jetzt. Die ersten Ubuntu-Versionen waren
eher so braun-rot. Install ging aber ziemlich zackig. Guck mal, man kann sogar Java-Gedöns
installieren. So, Visual Studio haben wir installiert. Discord kann man installieren.
Hieri. Was ist denn Hieri? Mail-Client. Mail in 2020, ich glaub's dann. Xfce, KDE, Plasma
oder Gnome. Das ist ziemlich sicher ein schräg normales Gnome hier. Oder meinst du, was
ich davon nehmen würde? Ich würde keins von den drei nehmen. Aber wenn ich was nehmen
müsste, dann würde ich Xfce nehmen. Ansonsten nehme ich immer i3. Es bin released. Do you
want to install? Install. Immer install. Excellent install. Was ich nehmen würde, wenn ich mich
zwischen den drei entscheiden müsste, KDE, Gnome oder Xfce, würde ich Xfce nehmen. Aber
eigentlich will ich keins von drei verwenden, sondern nehme i3. I3 beste. Übrigens noch
mal zur Anmerkung, weil es ein paar haben wollten. Und ich weiß, dass mit Sicherheit
nicht alle im letzten Stream dabei waren. Für diejenigen, die es interessiert, ich
hab aus dem Archlinux-Einricht-Stream habe ich die Config-Files bei mir auf GitHub gepusht.
Mit ein paar kleinen Anpassungen noch dazu, weil das einige Leute interessiert hat. Könnt
ihr gucken, wenn es euch interessiert. Was gibt es denn jetzt schönes Neues? Es gibt
neue Icons. Die finde ich eigentlich ganz hübsch. Könnte ich mir auf dem anderen auch erzählen.
Die haben standardmäßig so ein Zwischending. So ein halbes Dark-Theme ist es. Es ist kein
richtiges Dark-Theme, es ist nur so ein halbes Dark-Theme. Der Hintergrund ist relativ dunkel,
das hier oben ist relativ dunkel, aber Nautilus und so, das ist alles hell. So Terminal. Terminal
wird ein stinknormales Gnome-Terminal sein vermute ich mal. Aber sieht ganz brauchbar
aus. Und es hat mittlerweile keine komische Transparenz mehr. Das finde ich ziemlich
gut. Denn die Fault Ubuntu-Font mochte ich eigentlich schon immer. Ganz gut. Und das
Ubuntu-Font-Rendering sieht auch wieder ganz okay aus. Gucken wir uns das mal an, mal
ein bisschen größer. Da kann man sich nicht beschweren. Der Standard-Font ist gut und
das Font-Rendering ist auch sehr ordentlich. Da ist nichts irgendwie Klötzchen oder sonst
viel. Das sieht echt gut aus. Und besonders, wie sieht es klein aus? Das sieht auch gut
aus. Das können die echt ganz gut bei, in Afrika. In Südafrika. Also das sieht okay
aus. Was ist das für ein Knopf da oben? Ach so, ein neuer Tab. Suchen. Okay, kann man,
was sucht da drin? Cache. Ah, habe ich noch nie verwendet. Ich mache immer als erstes
mal einen T-Max auf und suche da drin. Na, über Snap. Über Snap. Ich brauche kein Snap
für T-Max. Das ist ja lieber aus dem Paket. Aus den Repos und gut ist. Ja, die kommen
aus Südafrika. Mal sie testen Big Macs, mal wir analysieren Fonts. Ich finde es gar nicht
so unwichtig, dass da der Standard-Font ordentlich ist, weil das eine Sache ist, wo Ubuntu gerade
auf dem Desktop lange Zeit total gekrankt hat. Also das Standard-Font-Rendering war
absolut grausam früher. Mittlerweile geht es, aber das Standard war so grottenschlecht
früher, da konnte es keinem zeigen. Das sieht Windows ohne True-Clear-Font viel besser aus.
Das sah absolut eklig aus früher. Und viele Distributionen haben da auch keinen Wert drauf
gelegt und haben gesagt, ja installiere doch sonst irgendwelche Zusatz-Fonts und wie heißt
der Font-Font, wie heißt der Kram unter Linux nochmal? Font-Config, genau. Irgendwelche
Custom-Font-Config-Patches und Gedöns. Jetzt haben sie es zumindest langsam gecheckt, dass
auch in einem Default-Zustand ein Text nicht pixelig aussehen sollte. Kennst du zufällig
den IBM Plexmono? Ich habe mir letztens zwei Fonts angeguckt. Und zwar habe ich mir einmal,
ich glaube das war von IBM, das kann sogar sein, dass das der war. Oder andere, die haben
jetzt bei JetBrains auch einen eigenen Font. Weiß ich nicht, ob ihr den schon gesehen
habt. Den können wir uns mal angucken, wie der hier gerendert wird unter Ubuntu. JetBrains
Mono haben die jetzt auch. Ne, den habe ich mir noch nicht angeguckt. Was zeichnet das
deiner Meinung nach aus? Ne, kenne ich nicht. Für was ist da gut geeignet, der Font? Das
neue Eclipse mal gesehen, welches? Dieses Tia, oder was meinste? Das ist doch kein neues
Eclipse, das ist doch so eine Cloud-IDE-Geschichte von Eclipse. Also das soll doch glaube ich
keine, kein Ersatz für normale Desktop Eclipse sein. Bester Mono Space von Firemono Medium.
Bester Mono Space ist immer noch. Heck, da geht nix drüber. Weder SourceCore Pro, noch
irgendwelche anderen Sachen. Heck ist der beste Font, den es gibt. Also extrem subjektiv.
Das ist wirklich Geschmackssache. So, und der ist jetzt auch neu. Und ich könnte mir
vorstellen, nachdem JetBrains ja viele Anhänger hat, was Programmier-IDEs und sonst was gehen,
könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass viele Leute jetzt auch Mono verwenden. Ach ja, und das
muss ich sagen, unter Windows, Konsolas finde ich auch gut. Und wie heißt das andere was
die früher hatten? Konsolas und Lucida Console ist das glaube ich früher das andere. Die
zwei Microsoft Sachen muss man unter dem mal zu gut halten, die sind auch ganz okay. Ein
Font, den ich auch sehr voll sidetracked wieder, aber da muss ich jetzt mal, der alte macOS
Default Font, den könnte ich mir zwar nicht lange geben im Terminal, aber ich finde den
sehr schön designt. MacOS Old Default Font. Mono Space. Tja, Monaco? War das Monaco?
Ja, Monaco war das, genau. Den finde ich echt gut gemacht, aber den könnte ich mir nicht
lange geben im Terminal. Ja, den da. Der ist mir ein bisschen zu schnörkelig. Ja, der
ist mir ein bisschen zu schnörkelig. Aber ich finde extrem hübsch den Font. Also das
ist auch wohl aus der Zeit wo Apple ordentliche Sachen designt konnte. Ich finde den sehr
hübsch den Font. Also einer der hübschsten Fonts den es gibt, den alten macOS Default
Font. Aber ich könnte ihn mir nicht lange geben im Terminal. Windings. Naja, das hat
jetzt eigentlich nichts zu tun. Okay, also mit Windows-Taste macht man nicht das Startmenü
auf. Wo ist überhaupt das Startmenü hier unten? Alt-Escape war es früher, nee. Ui,
was macht ein Alt-Escape? Was mache ich da gerade? Okay, ich weiß nicht was ich da mache.
Also Windows-Taste macht jetzt so ein Exposé-View. Das finde ich nice, das macht es aber schon
eine ganze Weile, das ist nichts Neues. Man muss jetzt sagen, seitdem die ihr Custom-Desktop
aufgegeben haben, gefällt mir Ubuntu Desktop deutlich besser wieder. Ich verwende es nicht,
ich bin mittlerweile bei der anderen Distribution im Desktop gelandet. Aber allemal besser
als Unity. Was ist eigentlich ein typischer Hacker-Font? So ein Terminus, Terminus ist
ein richtiger Hacker-Font. Ja, nee, das ist doch nicht Terminus. Terminus, was ist so ein
richtiger Hacker-Font? Das da, nee. Oder ist das Terminus? Keine Ahnung ob es Terminus
ist. Da gibt es eigentlich mal ein kleines Beispiel für, wenn die offizielle Font-Seite
noch nicht mal den eigenen Font verwendet. Wir installieren es jetzt einfach mal und
ich zeige euch Terminus. Das ist der Hacker-Font schlechthin, finde ich. Terminus haben
ich installiert, okay. Abt-Search, weiß gar nicht ob das noch drinnen ist. Ja, Abt-Install-Terminus,
wie heißt, X-Fonts, was? X-Fonts-Terminus, was beknackter Name. Nee, Fonts-Terminus.
Warum gibt es X-Fonts-Terminus und Terminus und Paketbenamung auf Doom wieder? Das ist,
das gerade könnte wirklich Pokemon sein, ja. Ja, das aber alles Mögliche. So, Custom-Font,
Terminus. Pass auf, jetzt wird es hässlich. Terminus, das ist der Hexer-Font, Leute. Und
jetzt können wir noch einstellen, Colors. Gibt's noch Grün? Gibt's noch Grün? Gibt's
immer, es gibt nur noch Crayon Black, Green on Black. Ah, yes, excellent Hacker-Font. So,
jetzt sind wir jetzt Hacker-Man. Huge. Jetzt haben wir es geschafft. Upgraded. Wie hieß
da nochmal dieses, ähm, das da? Wie hieß, wie hieß denn das nochmal? Das müssen wir
jetzt installen. Hollywood, das hieß einfach Hollywood, ne? Genau, ja, das brauchen wir,
das brauchen wir. Achtung. Nee, nee, nee, Matrix, Quatsch. Matrix, wir machen das viel
besser. Viel besser. Matrix ist out. Vielleicht, vielleicht, wir machen, wir machen mal zum,
zum einstimmen, zum einstimmen machen wir nochmal 10 Matrix. Aber das geht viel besser,
das, oh, ich sogar. Wobei, also das, das geht besser. Big X the 1, abonniert zwei Monate,
dankeschön. Huge Sub. Mal kurz schauen, dass ich keine Subs vergessen hab. Haben wir eigentlich
das Aquarium? Nein, fuck. Äh, hab nichts vergessen zum Glück. Aber jetzt passt mal auf, Hollywood.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt gehts ab. Im Hacker, im Hacker Look. Ah, yes. Exzellent, so muss das
sein. Report a problem, Ubuntu is ready. Das glaub ich nicht, dass Ubuntu ready ist für
den Kram, der hier gerade läuft. Du musst das Programm Hollywood installieren, dann
hast du das auch. So. Wie macht man das jetzt wieder aus? Wow, fuck. Okay. Geht doch sicher
auch unter Windows. Nee, das wird, wird wahrscheinlich nicht unter Windows gehen. Was? Irgendwas
has stopped. Weil Hollywood, fake nicht, Hollywood führt echte Programme aus und faked damit
Sachen. Also der, der führt wirklich da oben, äh, ein Filesystem LS aus und, und irgendwas,
der, der führt wirklich Dinge aus. Also man, die machen zwar nichts, aber die führt, führt
da wirklich aus. Ähm, na gut, du könnt, doch, du könnt's in WSL 2, könnt's das natürlich
laufen lassen. Raus da. So, genug Hacker-Font. Ich mach mal mein Terminal wieder normal.
Ähm, Text. Gut. Das wichtigste hab ich jetzt noch gar nicht geguckt. Haben die denn hack
als Font? Nicht kack. Hack. Hack-Font. Font-Hack. Es gibt einmal hack als TTF und einmal hack
als OTF. Ich muss euch ehrlich gestehen, ich habe bis heute nicht verstanden genau, was
der Unterschied ist zwischen TTF und OTF. Ist das das gleiche, nur in anderes Format
ist zu speichern? Ist das in Hollywood eine TMAX-Session? Es verwendet glaube ich nicht
TMAX, es verwendet irgendeinen anderen Terminal-Multiplexer, Terminal-Terminal-Window-Manager oder wie
er immer man es nennen mag, aber so was ähnliches. Ja, ihr habt irgendjemanden Ahnung von euch,
was der Unterschied ist zwischen TTF und OTF ist bei Fonts? OTF ist der offene Style, TTF
ist True-Type-Microsoft-Zeug. Ja, Font ist da gleich, ok. Aber eigentlich ist es doch
egal was ich installiere, solange mein Font-Render-Gedöns es versteht und wahrscheinlich versteht
es alles installen. Also ich brauche noch ordentlich Terminal-Font. Wobei der Default-Mono-Space
nicht schlecht ist von Ubuntu. Den fand ich schon immer recht hübsch. Heck. Ah, yes.
So gefällt mir das Terminal schon viel besser. Endlich ein ordentlicher Font. Exquisite,
Exzellent-Front. Wisst ihr, muss ich jetzt mal loswerden, was für mich schwierig ist
im Home-Office, muss ich gerade mal loswerden. Eine Sache die für mich schwierig ist im Home-Office
und zwar, ich meine, ich habe online jetzt nicht irgendwie so die ultra-fake-Personalität
wie das manche quasi fast schon schauspielermäßig machen. Also ich meine, ich bin zu 90% online
so wie ich offline auch bin, aber ich reiße mich offline mehr zusammen, was dummes Geschwätze
angeht oder irgendwie Twitch-Memes oder irgendwelche Pepe-Emotes und Zeug. Also da reiße ich mich
offline immer ein bisschen mehr zusammen und das geht recht einfach, weil ich halt offline
bin. Ja, also ich bin RL irgendwo und da kann ich mir ganz gut merken, so okay, jetzt sind
wir im Real-Life-Modus. Das fällt mir im Home-Office ein bisschen schwer. Ich merke schon, dass
ich immer unkontrollierter anfange, Emotes und Sachen in Teams zu pasten. Ich habe heute
beispielsweise schon fast, also ohne nachzudenken, Pepe-Hands in Chat gepostet auf der Arbeit.
Lustigerweise, einer hat es anscheinend verstanden, weil der hat es gleich geliked. Also erstmal
eine Runde Pepe-Hands reingepostet. Das ist halt schwierig, weil wenn man im Home-Office
sitzt, da ist überhaupt kein Unterschied. Weißt du, du sitzt vorm gleichen Rechner
mit der gleichen Hardware, gleicher Tastatur, gleicher Maus, gleicher Bildschirm. Sieht
genauso aus, bloß dass du jetzt ja eigentlich arbeiten musst. Es ist aber nicht schlimm,
man muss ja sagen, bei uns sind die meisten Leute jetzt ja technikaffin, was im Endeffekt
heißt, die können vielleicht nicht direkt was mit anfangen, aber die haben da auch keine
Probleme mit, wenn die Leute ein bisschen rumspinnen. Außer vielleicht, wenn jetzt einer
irgendeine Führungsdings-Präsentation halten soll und wird da Pepe-Hands rein machen.
Da wird man vielleicht ein bisschen doof gucken, aber wahrscheinlich würde das sogar durchgehen,
weil die sich dann sagen würden, naja gut, die IT-Leute, die haben sie eh nicht mehr
alle, da müssen wir nichts drauf geben. Ich sag manchmal mittlerweile schon excellent vor
mich hin. Ah, yes, excellent. Das ist so eine richtig doofe Angewohnheit, excellent zu sagen
in letzter Zeit. Ah, yes, excellent. Warum hat Ubuntu laufend Fehler? Application CCZE,
was ist denn das überhaupt? Bringt Farbe in die Logfiles, kackt eher ab anstatt, ne,
das ist irgendwas anderes, oder? Ubuntu. Ok, es kackt anscheinend ab. Wie hast du das
gerade gemacht? Die Größe von dem Fenster zu verändern wäre eine mittlere Maustaste.
Du hältst die Windows-Taste oder deine Meta-Taste gedrückt und machst mit der mittleren Maustaste
kannst du, du musst nicht immer am Rand gehen, da flippt man aus, wenn man am Rand ist, immer
am Rand muss. Ich muss mich da ein bisschen umgewöhnen, weil ich track und drop die Fenster
bei mir normalerweise mit Meta-Rechtsklick und das geht unter Ubuntu nicht. Bei welcher
Firma arbeitest du denn, dass du im Homeoffice bist? Also bei welcher sag ich nicht genau,
aber es ist eine Bank in Frankfurt. Da gibt's ja nicht so wenige, die da in Frage kommen
in Frankfurt. Achso, wir wollten uns das ZFS Zeug noch ein bisschen angucken. Was, List?
Ja. Gibt nur zwei Marken in Frankfurt. So sieht's aus. Revealed. Also wir haben zwei
ZFS Pools. Die... Ah, okay. Wir haben zwei Gigabyte fürs Boot für Boot und 55 Gigabyte
für den Rest. Eine Sache muss man sich nämlich merken, wenn man ZFS verwendet, ist es manchmal
nicht so ganz klar, wenn man DF macht für den Speicherplatz zu dem... Ach, wie ging
das andere nochmal? Was? ZFS List? Ah, ZFS List war das andere. Genau. Da ist es manchmal
nicht so ganz klar, ob das stimmt, was in DF-H steht. Man sollte lieber mit ZFS List gucken.
Da ist es auf jeden Fall genau. Ubuntu afklo. Nee, afpco. Alles klar. Beste. Ist das random
oder ist das irgendein südafrikanisches Wort? Afco. Ich will sagen, es liest sich wirklich
afklo. Schreib mal tree ins terminal. Oh no. Du meinst als color es? Not impressed. Wenn
man ein bisschen mehr Hacker aussehen will, Hacker, Hacker sein will, dann kann man wenigstens
mal sowas machen. Oh, das scrollen funktioniert nicht, weil ich keine t-marks-config drin
habe. Gut, also funktioniert wohl recht gut, dass man das Ganze mit ZFS installiert. Wie
ist denn so die Aufteilung hier? Also erstmal gucken, was die aktiviert haben. Zpool. Was
gab es noch? Status gab es noch, ne? Genau, keine Fehler. Alles online. Natürlich alles
nur auf einer Disc. Zpool. Was? Zpool. Zpool. Jetzt noch viel wichtiger, haben wir Auto
vervollständigen für ZFS? Ne, das haben wir natürlich nicht. IO-Stat gibt es aber. Ja,
wir sehen, dass er gerade nichts macht. Wie haben sie denn das so eingeteilt? Für meinen
Geschmack ein bisschen viel, ehrlich gesagt, was Default ist. Man muss ja nicht alles irgendwie
in ein eigenes Dataset hängen. Das ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen übertrieben. Also wir haben
einmal einen Pool für Boot, okay. Das haben wir ja vorher schon erfahren, das ist, weil
Crab wohl irgendwie Probleme hat, das zu booten. Wobei ich mich wundere, dass Crab Probleme
hat, das zu booten. Wir haben doch schon vor drei Jahren oder so mal, oder vor zwei Jahren
im Stream eine ZFS-Root-Partition gebootet. Also Crab, ich bin eigentlich ziemlich sicher,
dass Crab das kann. Aber vielleicht haben die andere Probleme. Weiß nicht. So, also
wir haben hier das eingerichtet. Wir haben einen extra Pool für Boot, dann haben wir
einen Pool für den Rest. So Airpool ist auch so mit der Default-Name. Oder Tank. Die Solaris-Leute
nennen das Ding immer Tank. Bob builds an army gegen Google+. Tank haben die Solaris-Leute
immer. Wir haben einen zweiten Pool, da haben wir einmal ein Root-Dataset drauf und ein
User-Data-Dataset. Finde ich eigentlich nicht schlecht. Das hier ist mir ein bisschen viel
ehrlich gesagt. Das muss man nicht alles auf ZFS. Da muss man nicht einzelne Mountpoints
und Geschiss machen. Also man kann es auch übertreiben. Log ist ganz sinnvoll als eigenes
zu machen, weil wenn man Snapshots macht und rollt was zurück, will man ja vielleicht
die Logs noch behalten, um zu gucken, was ist denn schief gelaufen, weshalb man zurück
gerollt hat. Aber den Rest könnte man eigentlich mehr oder weniger ins gleiche stecken. Naja,
was auch immer. Aber funktioniert gut. Dürfte eine der ersten Distributionen sein, die
ZFS im Installer drin haben. Ich glaube es gibt noch eins, zwei andere, aber viele gibt's
nicht. Also, was gibt's sonst noch Neues? Es fällt mir auf den ersten Blick, sieht mir
das relativ normal aus. Kann man noch komplett Dark-Theme einstellen? Yes, sehr schön. Das
finde ich gut, dass das mittlerweile funktioniert, weil ich spiele mir ein, das ging früher
auch nicht richtig. Also man kann komplett Dark-Theme machen, das finde ich schon mal
gut. So, das Dock kann man unten für die Windows-Fans, rechts, ich kenne niemand,
dass er ein Dock rechts hat oder links verwenden. Verwendest du zufällig die ZFS-Intent-Log-Funktionalität
für... Nö. Kennst, nee, verwend ich nicht. Ich habe mein ZFS relativ default. Einzige,
was ich gemacht habe, ist geguckt, dass das von den Blockgrößen passt und Kompression
angemacht. So, gibt's sonst noch was Neues? Nachdem ich zu faul bin, jetzt alles zu durchsuchen,
mal ob es eine Punkt 4... Oh Leute, mir fällt gerade ein. 20.04. Die Version ist problematisch.
Wisst ihr aber warum? Wer hat am 20.04. Geburtstag? Nicht, dass ich jetzt falsch liege.
Wer hatte Geburtstag am 20.04. Leute? Die Version, die ist kritisch. Ja, Sebaro hat
Recht. Ein Österreicher, korrekt. Allerdings interessiert ihr das in Südafrika wahrscheinlich
wenig. Wir hätten wahrscheinlich in Deutschland 20.04 übersprungen oder so. Bei solchen Wetter
tun wir uns mit so komplett unrelated Sachen, tun wir uns ja sehr schwer. Hat damit ja eigentlich
überhaupt nichts zu tun, aber ich glaube wir hätten echt ein Problem damit gehabt, wenn
das Ding 20.04 hieß. Achso Sebaro, ich dachte du hättest das so gewusst. Ich dachte hier,
die 5 Monate Sub, ne nicht die 5 Monate Sub, die 9 Monate Sub, die du bist, hätten schon
zu so hohem EQ geführt, dass du das weißt. Hatte leider Encryption für ZFS getestet als
es noch Plus auf Master war, aber noch nicht released, nach einem, äh, was? Was ist denn
dein Fupa? Achso, Smallbrain hatte ich gerade. Hat sich der Pool komplett verabschieden,
ist wohl einmal über die Meter dann drüber, das ist schlecht. Wir hatten es ausprobiert,
wir hatten es vor 2 Jahren oder so mal ausprobiert. Ich glaube auch im Stream, ist schon ewig
her, war einer der ersten Streams, die ich damals gemacht habe, ist schon eine ganze
Zeit her. Da hatten wir dann Ubuntu installiert mit ZFS auf verschlüsseltem, auf verschlüsseltem
Root. Und dann haben wir sogar noch eingerichtet per SSH unlocken. Das war ein Ack, da kann
ich mich dran erinnern, ich glaube da haben wir 6 Stunden dran gesessen bis das Scheiß
funktioniert hat. Damals, vor wie gesagt vor 2 Jahren, das war doch hochgradig Alpha
der ganze Mist. Ich weiß noch, wir haben installiert ZFS, Ubuntu on Root, encrypted und dann, dass
man beim booten unlocken konnte über SSH. Das war ein Ack, das ist mir im Gedächtnis
geblieben. Also suchen wir mal, 20.4 Features, was gibt's für neue Features? OMG Ubuntu
UK. Aha, das ist ein Fossa, Fossa. Zu was für einer Kategorie Tier gehört das? Ich
habe erst gedacht es könnte eine Katze sein, aber dafür sieht sie irgendwie nicht katzig
genug aus. Was ist denn ein Fossa? Fredkatze, Raubtierart. Das ist so ein Zwischending zwischen
Otter und Katze, oder? Katzenartige, ok es ist eine Katze. Es sieht halt echt aus wie
so eine Mischung aus Otter und Katze. Quasi ein Grotter. Nixor, Twitch hat gerade Probleme
mit dem Chat. Wobei ich nicht sicher bin, ob Twitch Probleme hat oder mal wieder Provider
in Deutschland Probleme mit dem Chat haben oder beide. Lustigerweise funktioniert das
mal mit Vodafone, ansonsten ist Vodafone eher die da. Also ich wäre lieber bei der Telekom,
wenn ich dort das gleiche an Bandbreite kriegen würde wie bei Vodafone. Was ich für Probleme
hatte schon hier mit Frame Drops und alles, das hatte ich bei der Telekom nie. Und ich
hatte lange Zeit zwei Anschlüsse parallel, dass wenn es abgekackt ist, ich einfach umschalten
konnte, aber das war mir irgendwann zu teuer und ich habe es nicht mal eingesehen, dass
ich doppelt bezahlen soll, weil wir es in Deutschland nicht geschissen kriegen unsere
Infrastruktur ordentlich auszubauen. Angeblich ein europäisches Routing-Problem. Also wenn
es ein europäisches Routing-Problem wäre, wäre Vodafone garantiert auch davon betroffen,
denn Vodafone ist ja von allen Routing-Problemen und mehr betroffen, wenn es die gibt. Also
man kann davon ausgehen, wenn man gucken will, ob es ein internationales Problem ist, guckt
man erstmal, ob Vodafone auch betroffen ist. Wenn Vodafone auch betroffen ist, dann ist
es ok. Es ist auf jeden Fall schon mal ein Problem. Es kann natürlich immer noch ein
reines Vodafone-Problem sein. Du könntest jetzt MP-TCP, Multipass-TCP oder was ist das?
Das ging doch mit Samba schon lange. Oder war das was anderes? Nee, das ist anscheinend
was anderes. Ich weiß, dass man mit Samba schon mehrere Netzwerk-Karten verwenden konnte.
Der Kelmore schreibt, Vodafone meinte heute zu mir, dass LTE in meiner Stadt komplett
überlastet ist. Krieg auch laufende Verbindungsabbrüche. Vodafone meint echt viel, wenn der Tag lang
ist. Ich hatte es euch ja mal erzählt, aber zur Erheiterung für alle, die nicht dabei
waren. Ich habe mich ja schon ein paar Mal beschwert bei Vodafone, weil hier im Stream
zeige ich euch ja mal. Heute ist es ziemlich gut. Guck mal Leute, null Dropped Frames,
das hatten wir noch nie. Ohne Scheiß. Das hatten wir noch nie, dass null Frames gedroppt
waren. Zumindest, ich habe mich ja öfters mal bei Vodafone ausgekotzt, wie schlecht
das Ganze ist. Also mit dem Twittersupport, weil der Twittersupport antwortet immer schön.
Da muss man echt sagen, hier easy clap. Twittersupport macht seinen Job gut, Vodafone an sich macht
seinen Job nicht gut. Die leiten einen immer an den Techniker weiter, blablabla. Da habe
ich mich, wo ich gerade beim Mexikaner, der Haftbefehl Mexikaner, Leute, die ich öfters
dabei wissen, wer der Haftbefehl Mexikaner ist, da habe ich gerade beim Haftbefehl Mexikaner
gesessen und da hat mich der Vodafone-Techniker angerufen und der Chat spoilert schon wieder
und nach langer, langer Rede, kurzer Sinn, der hat mir erst versucht zu erklären, was
Sache ist. Er hat überhaupt keinen Sinn ergeben und am Ende, wahrscheinlich, weil ihm sonst
nichts mal eingefallen ist, meinte er, das liegt daran, weil mein 2,4 GHz WLAN und mein
5 GHz WLAN die gleiche SSID haben. Deswegen hätte das Kabelmodem-Fehler. Ich wusste nicht
mehr, was ich sagen soll. Mir ist legit nichts eingefallen. Das ergibt so wenig Sinn, dass
mir da wirklich nichts eingefallen ist. Ich habe nur was gesagt in der Richtung so, aha,
leuchtet mir technisch 2 überhaupt nicht ein, aber meinetwegen. Ja, WLAN SSIDs. Vor allem
wisst ihr, was der Witz ist. Ich verwende noch nicht mal das eingebaute WLAN im, äh,
nicht Speedport, wie heißt das bei Vodafone. Oh, wie heißt die scheiß Box von Vodafone
nochmal? Connectbox. Dass die auch alles, dass die den Kram nicht irgendwie mal griffig
nennen können. Connectbox. Ich verwende ja noch nicht mal das WLAN in der Connectbox.
Ich habe meine eigenen Access Points, die wahrscheinlich dreimal so viel kosten wie
so eine kacke Connectbox, ähm, und verwende null von Vodafone. Gar nichts. Das einzige,
was ich von Vodafone verwende, von dieser Connectbox, ist wirklich das Kabelmodem, was
drinne ist. Also das Ding als Kabelmodem und als Notgedrungen als Router, ja. Router schrägst
dich Kabelmodem. Ich verwende nichts davon. Nichts. Äh, auch das WLAN nicht. Und da
wollte er mir wirklich erzählen, es liegt daran, dass ich an meinen Access Points, nicht
an den Unity Media Access Points, das hätte ich ja noch irgendwie verstanden, wenn das
Ding, keine Ahnung, wenn zu viel RAM braucht oder sonst was, ja. Also an meinen Access
Points, ähm, die SSID doppelt eingestellt sind, deswegen das Kabelmodem Fehler wirft.
Da hab ich echt am Verstand der Menschheit wieder gezweifelt. Connectbox ist Unity Media.
Ja, ich hab ja auch noch Unity Media, aber jetzt ist Unity Media ja Vodafone. Benutzt
eigentlich irgendwer ein eigenes Modem, kann das irgendwelche Vorteile haben? Naja, ähm,
wenn du es besonders, äh, ro haben willst, ja, also sprich, wenn du es besonders direkt
und viel selbst machen willst, kann das schon seine Vorteile haben. Du, du hast zum Beispiel
kein doppeltes Nutt mehr. Oder besser gesagt, du kannst doppeltes Nutt vermeiden, ja. Also,
du hast ja normalerweise dann auf Provider-Seite hast du dein, ähm, wir gehen jetzt mal davon
aus, du hast einen richtigen, echten, äh, Dual-Stack mit vollwertigem IPv4 und IPv6,
ansonsten hast du ja quasi Triple Nutt. Ähm, dann machst du einmal Nutt am Ausgang auf
IPv4 an deinem, äh, an deiner Connectbox und einmal wahrscheinlich Nutt an deinem,
an deiner Fritzbox oder anderen Router, den du dahinter hängen hast. Doppeltes Nutt ist
nicht so schön, vor allem wenn man Ports weiterleiten will nicht. Da kann sich das
schon lohnen. Wenn du Dual-Stack-Lite hast, kannst du es eh vergessen mit Port weiterleiten,
weil das funktioniert rein technisch gesehen nicht. IPv4. Mit IPv6 hast du das Problem
nicht, da gibt es genaue Adressen. Nixor schreibt, gestern war ein Vodafone-Techniker bei uns
im Büro, sah aus wie ein Montana-Black-Verschnitt. Meint FIFA 22 Pro zu sein, sagt Vodafone
das beste? Ja, ganz bestimmt. Ganz bestimmt. Glaube ich dir sofort. Äh, warum würde man
eine Connectbox und eine Fritzbox verwenden? Zum Beispiel, wenn man mehr, wenn man die
Funktionen einer Fritzbox verwenden will, die eine Connectbox nicht hat, oder aber wenn
man einen, wenn man VoIP verwenden will, nicht von Unity Media oder nicht von Vodafone, so
habe ich es zum Beispiel bei mir daheim. Ich verwende, obwohl mein Vodafone-Anschluss
VoIP bietet, verwende ich Voice-over-IP, also Telefon, von einem anderen Anbieter. Ganz
einfach aus dem Grund, weil ich keinen Bock mehr habe auf Festnetz-Nummer-Portierung.
Warum dann nicht direkt die Fritzbox? Kannste auch machen. Kannste auch machen. Natürlich,
warum nicht? Kannste auch machen. Musst Vodafone anrufen und sagen, ey, ich will meinen eigenen
Router verwenden, ich will mein eigenes Modem verwenden, macht mal. Kannste auch machen.
Ja, stimmt. Ich verwende hier auch nicht das Voice-over-IP von Unity Media, und zwar bin
ich bei Easybell und habe den billigsten Tarif, den es da gibt. Hier Internet und Telefon.
Ich brauche Telefon. Wo ist denn nur Telefon? Wo ist denn Telefon? Ich brauche nur Telefon.
Wo ist es denn? Ach, hier Privatkunden, ich bin bei Geschäftskunden. Telefon, ja. 299
Monat. Und der Vorteil davon ist, Eatsbell, genau. Easy, easy, easy. Du bist bei Zipgate.
Ne, bei Zipgate bin ich, ich bin nicht bei Zipgate. Hatte ich mal in Erwägung gezogen?
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich gesagt habe, ich nehme Easybell. Keine Ahnung. Ich weiß
nicht mehr. Vielleicht, weil das Portierungsformular klarer war. Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Hat glaube
ich keinen großartigen weiteren Sinn gehabt. Ich vermute mal, bei euch kostet es ähnlich
viel. Macht wahrscheinlich keinen großen Unterschied. Zumindest hat es den riesen Vorteil dadurch,
dass ich jetzt im Endeffekt nur noch Fernsehen und Internet über Vodafone verwende, dass
wenn ich mal wieder wechseln will zur Telekom, ist es überhaupt kein Problem. Da muss ich
keine Festnetznummer portieren, weil das Portieren der Festnetznummer war immer das ätzendste
überhaupt. Aber wir wollten ja mal gucken, was es hier noch Neues im aktuellen Ubuntu
gibt. Ja, bei VDSL funktioniert das. Wir reden ja vom Kabelmodem. Kabelmodem, wenn man eine
eigene Fritzbox mit Kabelmodem verwenden will, sieht das anders aus. Da müssen die dich
irgendwie freischalten. Ich vermute mal, die müssen in ihr, was auch immer dahinter ist,
ich kenne mich mit Kabeltechnik nicht aus, wahrscheinlich die Mac von deinem Modem oder
irgendeine Unique ID von deinem Modem eintragen, dass du überhaupt zugreifen darfst von dort.
Weil so eine klassische Authentifizierung machen die ja gar nicht mehr. Also bei DSL hast
du hier noch so ein richtiges Authentifizierungsverfahren mit Username und Nummer und bei Kabel ist
es einfach nur, aha, das Gerät kenne ich, den Anschluss kenne ich, der darf. Also ich
habe gesagt, dieses Gerät an diesem Anschluss. Das ist deutlich simpler. Und die müssen
es dann freischalten, dann kannst du deine eigene Fritzbox verwenden. Was halt übelst
nice ist, wenn es hier bei Ubuntu LTS Releases geht, dass die mindestens 5 Jahre supportet
sind. Wie gesagt, 1404 ist immer noch supportet, das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Mittlerweile,
ich glaube früher waren es 8 Jahre, jetzt sind es 5 Jahre, aber 1404, 8 Jahre ist übelst
geil oder? Ist das nicht richtig unsafe? Was meinst du, dass die keinen Benutzernamen verwenden
und so? Nö, ich glaube nicht, dass das großartig unsafe ist. Das muss ja an diesem Anschluss
sein, dass es funktioniert. Warum sollte man noch 1404 verwenden? Zum Beispiel, wenn man
bei meinem Kack-VM-Hoster ist. Ich habe euch ja erzählt, ich habe eine Lifetime-VM gekauft
vor 5 Jahren oder so. 35 Dollar Lifetime-VM, also einmal 35 Dollar bezahlt für immer eine
VM haben und dieser Anbieter, der ist mehr down als up, das ist der beschissenste Anbieter
aller Zeiten, der bietet nur 1404 an, als Installation. Man kann natürlich trotzdem
selbst dann 1804 oder 1804 installieren. Der hat mit diesem Deal bestimmt richtig Minus
gemacht, ja gehe ich auch von aus. Das haben glaube ich viel mehr gemacht als er wollte.
Ich bin ja da auch nur drauf gekommen, weil mich einer auf der Arbeit darauf hingewiesen
hat und hat gesagt, hier guck mal, hast du gesehen? Und der hat sich da schon 5 Kisten
wahrscheinlich geholt, habe ich mir auch mal eine geholt. Auf zu Contabo, nee, nee, nee,
mit dieser Billig-VM wechsle ich nicht. Diese Billig-VM verwende ich ja auch für nichts,
was irgendwie Relevanz hat. Diese VM verwende ich einzig und allein nur, wenn ich mal irgendwo
eine Public IPv4 Adresse brauche für irgendwelche SSH Tunnel oder sowas. Man hat sagenhafte
2 MB die Sekunde lesen schreiben bei denen. Einfach vor dem Haus mal aufgraben und easy
Internet gönnen. Ich glaube so einfach ist das nicht, vor dem Haus aufgraben und dort
mal nebenbei an so ein Kabel da sich dran stöpseln. So einfach ist das denke ich nicht.
Wenn das nämlich so einfach wäre und dass man die auch so einfach bescheißen könnte,
ich meine irgendjemand muss es ja geben, der einen Vertrag hat, wo diese MAC drauf läuft
an dieser Adresse, dann hätten die das auch anders gemacht. Ich glaube nicht, dass es
so einfach ist. Selbst wenn du ans Kabel dran kommst, du musst dich ja immer noch anstöpseln,
das ist ja nicht so einfach wie bei irgendeinem Switch, wo du dich dran stöpselst.
Niksor, dazu gibt es auch noch eine schöne Sache, weil er sagt, ich soll den Kram doch
einfach bei mir daheim laufen lassen. Mein tolles Rack, wisst ihr was daran zuerst kaputt
gegangen ist? Nicht Spoilern Chat, oder besser gesagt, die die es wissen, nichts sagen. Was
meint ihr was mir zuerst kaputt gegangen ist? Also ich habe hier unten eine USB, da drüber
habe ich einen Switch, wo sieht man das dann schön? Unten ist eine USB, Stromleiste, 10
Gigabit-Switch, einen normalen Switch, einen Patch-Panel und meine 4HE-Kiste. Was meint ihr,
was mir als erstes kaputt gegangen ist? Richtig, Clorox HD, die USB, das Ding, was ich habe,
dass der Kram mir nicht kaputt geht. Die USB ist mir verreckt, vor einem Monat oder so.
Jetzt läuft einfach alles ohne USB und funktioniert wieder. Also merke, USB macht mehr Down-Time
als keine USB. Von welchem Anbieter war die Cyber-Power? Das war eine Cyber-Power 600,
die da war das, genau die. Die da. Die ist aber nicht, also die Aussage, die ist kaputt
ist wahrscheinlich nicht ganz richtig. Wahrscheinlich ist einfach nur die Batterie kaputt. Der hättest
du eine, ja da kann natürlich nichts passieren, ist klar. Das könnte dir bei APC genauso
passieren, das könnte dir bei allen Anbietern passieren können. Ich glaube auch nicht,
dass die kaputt ist, ich glaube einfach, die Batterie ist kaputt. Oder was heißt kaputt,
die Batterie ist einfach nach längerer Zeit jetzt hinüber. Welche VM benutzt ihr jetzt?
Das ist jetzt das aktuelle 2004 Ubuntu. Was bei Linus Tech Tips ist auch erst die USB
abgebrannt. Mussten ein Loch in den Serverraum machen, um USB austauschen zu können. Bei
Linus Tech Tips, ich glaube nicht, dass die manchmal die Sachen so schlecht planen, wie
es in den Videos aussieht. Ich glaube die machen das absichtlich, dass sie ein Video
darüber machen können. Genauso wie den Server, woran ein Handstand drauf machen musste, dass
die CPUs richtig angepresst waren. Keiner kann so bescheuert sein, wirklich den Kram
so verkaufen wollen und so betreiben. Das macht man einfach für Show und für Videos.
Das macht es ja auch irgendwo unterhaltsam. Die tun ja auch bei Linus Tech Tips immer
so, als bauen die jetzt irgendwelche ganz wichtigen Systeme zusammen, die sie jetzt
sofort brauchen oder verkaufen wollen oder sonst was. Das sind einfach nur Systeme, die
sie wahrscheinlich für Showzwecke zusammenbauen. Die brauchen die gar nicht. Das sind ja auch
die einzigen, die ein Studio haben, was im Hintergrund aussieht wie eine Küche. Alle
anderen nehmen vielleicht in ihrer Küche auf und wollen, dass es aussieht wie ein
Studio, aber den ist umgedreht. Das läuft in Firmware Workstation.
Gibt es eine Möglichkeit, mehrere 4G Verbindungen zu bündeln? Du weißt, es ist Mobilfunk. Also
theoretisch geht das. Gibt es ein paar Varianten, aber das hat alles seine Problemchen. Also
was du auf jeden Fall brauchst, dass es ordentlich funktioniert ist, du brauchst auf der Gegenseite
was, wo du das terminieren kannst drauf. Du kannst natürlich so eine Art Load Balancing
machen über vier Verbindungen, dann bringt das aber nur was, wenn du mehrere Clients
hast. Also du wirst das nicht schaffen, ohne dass du eine Gegenseite hast, wo du deine virtuelle
Verbindung drauf terminieren kannst, dass du beispielsweise einen Download machen kannst,
der dann auf einmal die Geschwindigkeit von vier Verbindungen hat. Das wird nicht funktionieren.
Was du machen kannst, ist, wenn du im Internet eine Kiste hast und bei dir lokal eine Kiste,
was was ich, du hast im lokal eine Kiste mit deinen, wie auch immer du sie angeschlossen
hast, deinen vier mal 4G Verbindungen oder deinen mehrere 4G Verbindungen, du hast im
Internet eine Kiste, da kannst du das darüber tunneln, damit, ich frage mich jetzt billig
aus dem Kopf, was man da alles für Zeug für braucht. Und das kannst du dann quasi so
zusammenfassen, dass es wie eine normale Layer 2 Verbindung aussieht, für alles was
da drüber geht. Da musst du dann auch einstellen, das ist übel, das ist schon ordentlich kompliziert.
Es ist auf jeden Fall nicht so easy. So, und dann kannst du nämlich so quasi für die
Geräte, die das verwenden, am Endeffekt sieht das dann so aus, als ist es halt eine Verbindung.
Das ist nicht eine Verbindung, das ist halt ein Kabel im Endeffekt, also es ist ein langes
Kabel dahin. Das hat aber alles seine Vor- und Nachteile und ist eklig. Ich habe mein
Abschlussprojekt über was ähnliches gemacht. Ich habe eine Layer 2 VPN gebaut, um Telefone
an eine Telefonanlage anzubinden. Und das hatte auch eine Backup-Verbindung. Wohlgemerkt,
nicht beides Active-Active, sondern Backup. Und das ist nicht ohne. Und schön ist es nicht.
Ob es war so billig, gehen tut es, aber nicht schön. Ich kann dir nicht empfehlen. Hört
sich so an, als würde es sich nicht austanen. Also richtig probiert habe ich es noch nicht.
Was ich noch nie probiert habe ist, irgendwie mal drei Internetanschlüsse versuchen zu
bündeln. Zumindest was alle, ein Problem gibt es bei allen diesen Techniken, die Anschlüsse
sollten ungefähr gleich schnell sein. Aber es ist also, es rentiert sich nicht, einen
16 MBit DSL und eine 400 MBit Unity-Media-Leitung zu bündeln. Aber wenn du quasi viermal die
gleiche Technik hast, dann kann das durchaus gehen. Da muss man sich einfach mal in Ruhe
einlesen und verschiedene Tutorials angucken, was man da so machen kann. Und es gibt nicht
nur eine Lösung, so wie das unter Lieblings-Immer ist. Was hältst du von VxLan? Das ist eine
gute Frage, ich habe keine Ahnung, was VxLan ist. Wie LAN? Ja, aber was ist VxLan? Alter
LAN. Was ist VxLan? Virtual Extensible LAN. Was? Kann das mal losgehen hier?
Oh, der Dr. Mario Corona Song hier. Die dazu dient die Probleme, die in sehr großer Umgebung
durch die beschränkte Anzahl von WLANs auftreten können. Fuck, was ist die Fault WLAN 4096?
Was ist so die normale maximale WLAN Anzahl 4096? Also ich weiß, dass bei Ubiquiti Switchen
ist mit der normalen Firmware bei 256 Schluss und mit der Extended Firmware geht glaube
ich mehr. Aber das ist was, wenn man mit 4096 nicht auskommt. Ich muss dir ehrlich sagen,
ich hatte noch nie mit einem, also Netzwerk-Admin technisch, mit einem so großen System
zu tun, dass 4096 WLANs nicht gereicht haben. Ich bin aber auch kein Netzwerk-Mann. Kenn
ich nicht. Keine Ahnung. Ach, mit VxLan kann man auch Leer-2 tunnen. Wie gesagt, es gibt
nicht nur eine Lösung. War ja klar. So, also was haben wir noch schönes hier in Ubuntu
drinne? Was können wir uns da angucken? Beta Freeze, ja das wissen wir, deswegen probieren
wir ja geradeaus. Das ganze kommt dann Release. Wann ist Release? Release? Wann ist Release?
Wird das denn irgendwo? Das ist immer Ende des Monats dann. Was oben drüber? Ach so,
23. April, okay. Also man könnte sogar sagen, wenn man sich jetzt eine neue Kiste installiert,
die man ein bisschen länger betreiben will, vielleicht könnte man das schon mit 20.04
machen, sofern alles funktioniert, was man haben will. Lange dauert es nicht mehr. Was
eigentlich für einen Colonel drauf haben wir gar nicht geguckt? Was zum WTF habe ich
jetzt gemacht? Was haben wir für einen Colonel drauf? Einen 5.4, das ist glaube ich einer
vor dem aktuellen. Aktuell ist 5.5. Nee, 5.6 ist gerade RC. 5.6 ist noch nicht raus. Oder
ist 5.6 mittlerweile raus? Ah, vor 5. Ich habe nichts gesagt. 5.6 ist raus vor 5 Tagen.
Ich habe nichts gesagt. Habe ich nicht mitgekriegt. Ach doch, klar habe ich mitgekriegt. Das ist
mit WireGuard mittlerweile drin. Ja klar. Aber ich wusste nicht, dass das schon raus
ist. Da müssen wir doch gleich mal gucken. Da müssen wir doch gleich mal gucken, was
unsere Manjaro-VM da so sagt. Erstmal updaten. Gibt es da schon den neuen Colonel? Nee, da
gibt es nur RC7. Ist noch nicht angekommen. Was ist das hier? Was haben wir sonst noch
für schöne neue Sachen hier im aktuellen Ubuntu drin? LTS-Releases, bla bla bla. You
can turn on dark mode. Das haben wir lustigerweise schon so gefunden. Ja, das Maskottchen interessiert
mich jetzt nicht die Bohne. Amazon-Launcher ist weg. Stimmt. Amazon ist weg. Wahrscheinlich
haben sie damit kein Geld mehr verdient. Ja, das ist gut, das Amazon. Das ging mir immer
auf den Sack früher. Stimmt. Ich habe es mir gar nicht aufgefallen. Ich habe es gar
nicht vermisst. Smallchains user will appreciate greatly. Ja, das stimmt. Ubuntu Software Store
is now a snap-based version. Das heißt, alles was ich über die Paketverwaltung installiert
habe ist jetzt ein Snap. Oder auch nicht. Slow Calculator Loading Times. Jetzt ernsthaft
Linux beziehungsweise GNOME, ist das wirklich euer Ernst, dass er fucking Calculator langsam
lädt? Ne. Ach, die meinen den UI Store. Die haben wir noch gar nicht angeguckt. Den da,
den hier. GNOME 3. So wirklich viel ist da nicht drin. Was ich persönlich aber sehr
begrüße, dass da nichts großartiges drin ist. Erstens ist es ein LTS-Release. Da müssen
Sie sich die nächsten Jahre darum kümmern. Und zweitens, wo ich bei Ubuntu wirklich keinen
Bock drauf habe, ist auf irgendwelche neuen Ubuntu Einzelaktionen. Ich meine, wer hat
bitteschön gesagt, ich möchte meine Netzwerk-Config in der Jaml-Datei machen? Wer ist bei Canonical
auf die großartige Idee gekommen und hat Netplan eingeführt? Das ist, ich kenne keine andere
Distribution, die den Kram verwendet und ich finde es unglaublich bescheuert, meine Netzwerk-Config
über eine Jaml-Datei editieren zu müssen. Das finde ich richtig beschissen. Zumal man
ja sagen muss, also man muss es ja gar nicht verwenden. Aber es wird halt empfohlen, das
ist halt die Fault mittlerweile. Ich persönlich muss ja sagen, so als jemand, der den Kram
schon zwölf, vierzehn Jahre oder so verwendet, mal vorneweg seit 2007, dreizehn, vierzehn,
ja länger noch. Also der quasi schon vierzehn, fünfzehn Jahre den Kram verwendet. Ich fand
ja die ganz alte Debian-ETC-Interfaces-Geschichte, meine persönliche Meinung ja, fand ich die
eigentlich am angenehmsten. Du hattest stinknormale Config-Dateien, da konntest du alles konfigurieren
an deinem Interface, das inklusive Bridges und irgendwelche Interface-Optionen konntest
du drin definieren. Da hast du gesagt Interface up und dann hat er alle Config geladen und
du hast gesagt Interface down und das Interface war wieder weg. So, das war relativ simpel.
So, mittlerweile hat man ja zig Varianten, wie man das machen kann. Man kann das über
System-D, Network-D machen, man kann das im Desktop-Bereich mit Network-Manager machen
und natürlich auch über DRCP, aber gut, das ging ja schon immer. Und warum brauche
ich dann sowas wie Netplan mit einer YAML-Config noch oben drauf? Verstehe ich nicht, leuchtet
mir nicht ein. Ja, mir war nicht X11-Alternative, mir war glaube ich Wayland-Alternative, ist
aber nie aus den Schulen gekommen, allerdings Wayland selber ja auch nicht, ich sag grad
der Witz, die kriegen es ja auch nicht gebacken. Bitte noch mehr Möglichkeiten. So, wir wollen
uns den Store angucken, da ist er. Warum haben die so einen komischen, so einen komischen
Orangen? Weil es Ubuntu ist wahrscheinlich. Oh, man kann Kubernetes installieren, das
brauchen wir unbedingt bei uns auf dem Desktop, wir brauchen unbedingt ein Kubernetes. Hat
mich vorher im Chat nicht jemand gefragt, wie ich Powerline finde? Hab ich gar nicht
beantwortet, ne? Müssen wir mal schauen, ob wir das hier irgendwie drin haben. Ah ne,
aber Schalter war es, nicht Powerline. Ok. Wisst ihr, deswegen ist mein Chatlogger ganz
gut. Die Fragen gehen wir gleich durch, wenn wir uns das fertig angeguckt haben. Ich muss
ja heute nicht, Punkt 22 ins Bett morgen ist ja frei. Wartet mal kurz, war süß. Ah,
die Katze. Och Chico, was ist denn los? Die Katze hat an der Tür gekratzt, die wollte
unbedingt rein. Chico, was ist los? Komm mal her. Komm mal her. Ja feine Katze, ja. Und
jetzt? Nur mal so, dass ihr ungefähr eine Vorstellung habt, was gerade hier sich bei
mir auf dem Schrank breit macht. Chico, wo habe ich das Bild von meiner Katze hin? Ja.
So, dass ihr ungefähr eine Vorstellung habt, was sich bei mir gerade auf dem Schrank breit
macht. Oder versucht hat. Chico, wo bist du hin? Ach, da. Was ist? Auch die stellst du
hier bei mir unter dem Tisch rum. Zeig Katz FPS live. Ne, wie soll ich das live zeigen?
Chico, was ist denn? Ja, ist ja gut. Gut, weiter geht's. Also das ist jetzt Snap passiert,
oder wie? Das heißt, wenn ich hier jetzt was installiere, was können wir denn mal installieren?
Kann man hier drinnen suchen ordentlich? Komm, wir installieren mal die Arduino IDE. Mit
der mache ich zwar nichts, selbst wenn man Arduino macht, aber wir können mal gucken,
ob das jetzt ein Snap ist oder nicht. Snap List. Tatsächlich. Aber warum? Warum ist das
jetzt alles ein Snap? Auf der anderen Seite ist das nicht schlecht, dass es ein Snap ist,
dann ist es jetzt wenigstens rückstandsfrei wieder weg. Ist auch okay. Also finde ich
nicht schlimm, dass das Snap passiert ist. Das einzige Problem an einem Snap-basierten
Paketmanager ist, dass, ich meine, es gibt halt nicht so wahnsinnig viel als Snap. Es
gibt schon einige Sachen, aber es ist lange davon entfernt, wirklich vollständig zu sein.
Discord können wir als Snap installieren. Na gut. Ja, großartige Änderungen gibt es
anscheinend ja nicht im aktuellen Ubuntu. Ich will mir jetzt noch mal schnell den Server-Installer
angucken. Ich wollte mir jetzt noch mal schnell den Server-Installer angucken, ob sich da
irgendwas geändert hat. Weil ich habe keinen Bock, wenn das raus ist, irgendwann wieder
Server-Installationen zu machen und festzustellen, die haben wieder irgendwie, das haben sie
ja schon mal gemacht vor zwei Versionen oder so, dass der Standard-Server-Installer auf
einmal so was ganz merkwürdiges war, wo du nichts mehr einstellen konntest und dann
musstest du ein anderes ISO runterladen als bisher, um den normalen Installer zu kriegen.
Schauen wir mal, ob das immer noch der Fall ist und wenn ja, was für ein ISO wir uns
jetzt runterladen müssen, dass es überhaupt funktioniert. Download. Ubuntu. Server. Yes.
CD. Englisch. Install. Mal gucken, ob sie das jetzt hingekriegt haben, ob das jetzt wieder
der Kack-Installer ist oder ob das jetzt der ordentliche Installer ist, den man wieder
kriegt bei der Server-Installation. Hat Ubuntu auch MS-Teams? Da habe ich jetzt leider nicht
geguckt. Aber na gut, nachdem das Snap basiert ist, gucken wir einfach mal. Wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich. Snap-Craft. Store. Gucken wir mal. Teams. Sieht nicht so. Doch. Gibt
es eigentlich einen offiziellen Teams-Kline für Linux? Ich verwende das immer nur im
Browser. Teams. Linux. Download. Gibt es einen offiziellen? Ok. Tja, dann gibt es den offiziellen
Teams-Kline anscheinend nicht. Es gibt nur einen inoffiziellen Teams-Kline. Die Frage,
die sich mir stellt natürlich, wenn es nur einen inoffiziellen Teams-Kline gibt und aber
auch einen offiziellen Teams-Kline. Warum gibt es einen inoffiziellen Teams-Kline, wenn
es einen offiziellen Teams-Kline gibt? Man weiß es nicht. Oh, das ist ja immer noch
der eklige Installer. Ich weiß nicht, was die dort geritten hat bei diesem Installer.
Das vor allem bei Workstation ist das. Passt mal auf. Wir gucken uns das jetzt mal an.
Das letzte Mal, als die den normalen Server Installer zu diesem Installer geändert haben,
konntest du nichts mehr einstellen. Das war eine absolute Zumutung. Mal gucken, wie das
jetzt ist, ob die das noch angepasst haben. Ja, ich weiß, es gibt einen Alternativ Installer.
Das ist auch der Einzige, den man verwenden kann, richtig. Englisch. Was? Yes, Installer
updaten. Warum nicht? Zubiquiti. So. Layout German. Warum braucht man eigentlich zwei
Server Installer? Das habe ich auch nicht so ganz verstanden. German. Dann. Ach, auch
gut. Dann. Dann. Dann. Entire Disk. Jawoll. Dann. BIOS. Ja, ist okay. Wir haben keinen
EFI Boot. Pick. Keine Ahnung. Hier. Max. Your server's name. Pog. Was? Only characters.
Aber man kann nicht groß schreiben. Was? Q. Buntu. Installer. Ich überlege gerade,
was hat mir jetzt an dem Server Installer mal noch nicht gefallen? Irgendetwas hat
mir das letzte Mal überhaupt gar nicht dran gefallen. Bis jetzt scheint es auch ganz,
ganz okay auszusehen. Ich meine, nicht, dass man davon irgendwie großartig jetzt standardmäßig
was bräuchte. Prometheus könnte man dann mal gucken. Machen wir mal drauf. Ach, brauchen
wir nicht. Wozu ist die Testkiste? SSH läuft standardmäßig. Ich weiß, ich weiß nicht
mehr, warum ich so eine Abneigung gegen diesen Installer hatte. Irgendetwas hat mir überhaupt
nicht gefallen an dem Installer, weil ich habe bisher immer die Alternate-Version runter.
Also irgendwas muss mich so abgeschreckt haben an dem neuen Installer, dass ich mir
gedacht habe, ne. Weil er beim Release des Todes verbackt war. Ich bilde mir auch ein,
es waren ein paar Sachen nicht drin, die jetzt gehen. Sowas wie SSH oder so. Irgendetwas,
ich weiß wirklich, ich weiß nicht mehr was. Aber irgendwas hat mich so abgefuckt, dass
ich im Kopf habe die ganze Zeit, ich muss den Alternate-Installer verwenden. Okay, das
war es anscheinend. Reboot. Pass auf, jetzt geht es nicht.
Was macht der da? What the fuck? Erstmal, erstmal einen VPN nach Südafrika aufbauen.
Wann zockst du mal was? Ich zocke eher offstream gerade. Okay, ich weiß nicht mehr, warum ich
so eine Abneigung gegen den Ubuntu Installer hatte. Moin Nelly Pock. Ich weiß nicht mehr,
was ich da für eine Abneigung gegen hatte. Weil bis jetzt hatte eigentlich ganz gut
funktioniert. Sieht aus wie ein ganz normales Ubuntu Server jetzt. Was halt blöd ist, dass
es immer noch diese Netplan-Geschichte ist. Ich meine, warum muss ich mein Netzwerk so
konfigurieren? Warum kann ich es nicht ordentlich konfigurieren? Da ist Snap drauf, ja das ist
auch eine Sache, die wir negativ aufkommen. Es ist Snap drauf und es ist anscheinend LXC
standardmäßig mit drauf. Finde ich auch überflüssig, braucht man auch nicht. Hollywood draufnehmen,
müssen wir gleich nachinstallieren. Muss sein, Hollywood. Das ist jetzt richtig Hacker. Hollywood
nur über die Konsole. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das überhaupt geht. Hollywood. Ah, yes,
excellent. Erst mal eine Runde Hacker-Man. Wisst ihr was? Ich habe mir schon öfters
mal überlegt, was mache ich in Videos, wo ich einfach mal 10 Minuten über aktuelle
Technik labere. Was mache ich da im Hintergrund, das was passiert? Einfach, mache ich sowas
im Hintergrund, ist es doch top? Also nein, ist es nicht top. Es ist wenn schon hart top,
aber auch nicht nur. Weil dann mache ich so, dann blende ich einfach sowas, einer passiert
was im Hintergrund, ja. Und dann blende ich immer gerade zu dem Thema, was ich labere,
passend die Bilder ein, ja. Oder das Aquarium oder so. Sehr schön. Gut. Also, es ist ein
bisschen viel, es ist ein bisschen viel Zeugs dabei mit dem neuen Server-Installer. Ne,
das habe ich jetzt nachinstalliert, das war nicht dabei. Das Battlefield-Video, das kommt
dieses Wochenende 100 pro. Ich habe jetzt auch wirklich mehr als genug Einsendungen.
Ich weiß wirklich nicht mehr, was ich für eine Abneigung gegen den neuen Server-Installer
hatte. Alles in allem ist ok. Ich meine, dass da Snap standardmäßig drauf ist, dass da
LXC standardmäßig drauf ist, braucht man nicht unbedingt, ja. Aber es ist jetzt auch
nicht so schlimm. Weil zumindest LXC verwende ich immer noch ganz gerne, um ein paar Sachen
auszuprobieren und wieder wegzuschmeißen. Das habe ich eh drauf. Was ich halt merkwürdig
finde, ist, dass sie das jetzt nicht mal selbst aus den Paketquellen mitliefern, sondern über
Snap installieren. Am Anfang konnte man keine festen IPs vergeben. Oh, das könnte
es tatsächlich sein. Das könnte es tatsächlich sein, dass ich da ein Problem mit hatte. Ja,
weil meine Kisten, also die Kisten, die dauerhaft laufen, die kriegen immer noch feste IPs.
Das mache ich aber mittlerweile auch nicht mehr. Mittlerweile kriegen die eine feste
DHCP-Reservierung, weil ich zu faul bin, das immer einzustellen von Hand. Abinstall, das
können wir noch machen. Install DockerIO. Was kriegen wir da für eine Version mit? Was
spricht eigentlich aktuell gegen CentOS? Nix, gar nichts. CentOS ist ein super, super
sauberer Betriebssystem. Mir persönlich gefällt einfach Ubuntu lieber. Auf der Arbeit haben
wir nur CentOS. Vielleicht mag ich deswegen für meinen privaten Kisten Ubuntu, weiß
nicht. Was mir an Ubuntu gefällt, ist so das Gesamtpaket eigentlich. Die Paketauswahl
ist gut. Die Server-Minimalinstallation ist ziemlich minimal. Ich meine, das ist debial
mit ein bisschen Gedöns. Also die Paketauswahl finde ich gut, was zur Verfügung steht. Es
steht auch ein bisschen exotischere Sachen zur Verfügung, wie beispielsweise ein gescheiter
Bash Prompt, was ich auch persönlich auf Servern praktisch finde. Da klont man sich
vielleicht auch mal einen Git Repo oder möchte ein paar Sachen in der Shell angezeigt bekommen.
Bei Ubuntu finde ich den hier ganz gut. Liquid Prompt. So Gedöns hast du halt dann bei Ubuntu
dabei. Find ich ganz schick. Der zeigt dir dann auch die Temperatur an von deinem System,
der zeigt dir an, falls du doch mal eine Git Repo auscheckst, in welchem Brand du bist
und sowas. Ist einfach schön, dass das standardmäßig in den Repos drin ist. Ich bin mir nicht
sicher, ob CentOS nicht vielleicht auch drin ist. Aber CentOS ist halt sehr klassisch,
was die mit liefern. Mir gefällt Abt besser als Jam oder DNF oder was auch immer, die
die jetzt mittlerweile noch haben. Abt finde ich ist neben dem von Arch Linux das Bequemste
und das Angenehmste. Ubuntu hat auch ein paar Sachen, die mir auf den Sack gehen, bis denn
Siebaro, wie diese Netconfig, Netplan-Geschichte, Jammel-Dateien für Netzwerk-Config, sowas
bescheuertes. Sie haben kein ASCII-Quarium dabei, das ist natürlich schon mal, das geht
ja gar nicht. Aber dafür, wie gesagt, dafür haben sie das Hacker-Tool schlechthin dabei,
das ist wichtig. Ah, yes, exzellent. Ist SL drauf wahrscheinlich, ja. Leute, ich gebe
alles. Ähm, da fällt mir eine Geschichte ein, die, äh, wo uns mal unser Ober-Oberchef
besucht hat, auf der Arbeit. Es ist ja so, dass wir, es gibt da schon mehrere Geschichten,
ja, und der Ober-Obertyp ist nicht der IT-Vorstandsmann, sondern der Obervorstandsmann. Und der war
mal unterwegs und wollte, wollte irgendwas, irgendwelchen Außendienstmitarbeitern, genau,
irgendwelchen Außendienstmitarbeitern wollte, der unsere, äh, unsere, unsere IT-Profis
wollte da zeigen, ja, wie, wie, wie geil, wie geil die IT in der Bank ist. Und natürlich
kommt er nicht einfach vorbei und bringt irgendwie 20 Außendienstleute mit, also quasi Leute,
die was verkaufen, der hat jetzt auch nicht irgendwelche random Außendienstleute mitgebracht,
sondern halt, wahrscheinlich war das ein Bonus für die, die besonders viel verdient haben,
so nach dem Motto hier, wir zeigen, wir, Grundgang in der Zentrale oder so. Und, ähm, natürlich
hat er sich vorher angekündigt, weil so ganz unvorbereitet geht das nicht und, ähm, wobei,
ne, das sind, das sind zwei unterschiedliche Geschichten. Ähm, das andere muss ich aber
danach auch noch erzählen. Zumindest hat er sich angekündigt und da haben wir schon extra
geguckt, dass in dem einen Raum, das ist, ähm, quasi, wir haben einen extra Großraumbüro,
wo unsere Leute sitzen, die 24-7 Monitoring machen, da hängt eine große Monitorwand
und so, das ist halt der Raum, der am meisten hermacht. Ähm, und da haben sie ihn halt
rumgeführt. Zumindest haben wir uns alle dann darüber gesetzt, dass es da halt schön beschäftigt
aussieht, dass da viel los ist. Und da haben wir uns im Vorfeld schon überlegt und da haben
auch unsere Chefs gesagt, ja, es wäre schön, wenn wir ein bisschen, wenn wir ein bisschen
beschäftigt tun könnten. Und da haben wir uns halt hingesetzt und überlegt, okay, was
machen wir? Und da haben wir uns dann drauf geeinigt, okay, äh, ein paar Leute setzen
sich halt nebeneinander und gucken dann bei jeweils anderen auf den Bildschirm interessiert
und der andere macht halt irgendwas. Und dann haben wir halt überlegt, ja, fuck, was machen
wir denn jetzt an? Und da haben wir dann halt sowas hier gemacht. Da haben wir dann hier,
mein Freund, ich brauch noch einen T-Maxx. Äh, da haben wir dann, da hab ich halt sowas
hier angemacht. Äh, was weiß ich, was ich noch laufen kann. Ich glaub, ein D-Stat hatte
ich noch laufen und, und irgendwie an noch Zeug hatte ich dann laufen, auf jeden Fall.
Sah halt übelst, übelst Hacker-Style aus. Und mein, mein Sitznachbar hat irgendwie
35 Cluster, also 35 SSH-Fenster auf gehabt. Sah halt übelst Hacker-mäßig aus. Da ging's
voll ab. Hat gedacht, Wunder, was hier gerade, was hier gerade bahnbrechendes geforscht wird
anscheinend. Da kamen sie halt rein, haben sich umgeguckt und sind dann auch mal zu den
einzelnen Leuten gegangen, so ein bisschen Smalltalk, blablabla, haha, und wie toll wir
sind. Und dann guckt er so bei meinem Kollege neben auf den Bildschirm und sagt so, oh,
davon versteh ich ja gar nix. Da war ja bei seinen 35 SSH-Fenster auf hatte. Ich hatte
halt einen Webbrowser auf, da guckt er bei mir so auf den Bildschirm und meint, ah ja,
damit kenn ich mich aus. Da hab ich halt nur so gesagt, Moment, haha, hab ich umgeschaltet
hier drauf und dann hat er gesagt, ohje, ohje, ich, äh, hat er irgendwie einen blöden Witz
gemacht, so. Und da hab ich drauf gesagt, damals, ähm, ich weiß gar nicht, wie es genau
gewesen ist. Der hat irgendwas gesagt, so hab ich gesagt, oh, da hab ich keine Ahnung von.
Da hab ich gesagt, ja, wir haben das jetzt ja auch gerade extra aufgemacht, weil wir
gehört haben, sie kommen vorbei. Und da hat er gesagt, haha, hab ich mir gedacht, okay,
wenn du wüsstest, dass das jetzt einfach die Wahrheit war, die ich dir erzählen hab,
hat er nicht geglaubt. Er hat gesagt, ja, wir haben das jetzt ja auch extra aufgemacht,
weil sie kommen. Und da hat er so richtig so sein, haha, guter Witz, Lache gemacht. Und
danach haben wir uns angeguckt und haben gesagt, eigentlich haben wir nur erzählt, wie es war.
Aber ich glaube, der Typ ist nicht blöd. Ich glaube, der weiß das schon. Richtig, ja,
das ist meta-gebated, das ist quasi gebated, obwohl der andere denkt, es ist nicht gebated
und es ist dann wirklich nicht gebated, falls es echt ist. Das ist also wirklich schon next
level. So, und da gibt es noch eine andere Sache, die kann ich jetzt auch noch mal kurz
zum Besten geben, weil ich muss ja, wie gesagt, ich muss ja, ich muss ja demnächst dann gleich
weg. Ähm, wir waren noch mal Hacker Tools an hier. Ähm, eine Geschichte kann ich auch
noch mal zum Besten geben. Wir haben einen Werbefilm gedreht. Oder besser gesagt, es,
eine Werbefirma hatte den Auftrag, über unsere, über die IT in unserer Zentrale einen Werbefilm
zu drehen. So rum. Und die sind dann angerückt und wir saßen halt alle da. Wir haben uns
natürlich mal wieder ein bisschen, bisschen mehr Leute dahingesetzt, als da normalerweise
sitzen und das hat denen nicht gefallen. Das waren halt nur Männer, weiße Männer, im Alter
von 20 bis 40. Und das war nicht, ähm, nicht divers genug für den Film. Deswegen wurde
dann gefaked, was das Zeug hält, Alter. Da haben Leute gesessen später in dem Video,
in diesem Büro. Die wussten nicht mal, wo der Raum ist zu dem damaligen Zeitpunkt.
Wir hatten dann im Endeffekt drei Mädels da sitzen. Drei Mädels noch da sitzen. Einen
alten Typ mit irgendwie, keine Ahnung, der war wahrscheinlich schon in der Rente oder
so, mit grauen Haaren und alles. Einen mit Kopftuch, einen schwarzen. Wir hatten alles.
Wir waren ohne Scheiß, wir waren, in diesem Video, waren wir die diverseste Abteilung
auf diesem Planeten. Also besser als jedes Microsoft Werbematerial. Es war wirklich,
es war alles bei. Wir hatten sogar Leute mit Tätowierungen dabei. Alles. Alles. Das war
so krass divers, dass der Film, das war wahrscheinlich der, der stylischste, ähm, Hipster und NG-Film
aller Zeiten. Echsenmenschen hatten wir nicht drin, ne. Und was ich halt witzig fand, dass
die dann wirklich Leute, was dann witzig war, wer dann da gesessen hat, ne. Es ist ja nicht
so, dass da irgendwie IT-Leute da gesessen hätten. Da saß dann einer von der QS, also
von der Qualitätssicherung. Es saß, ähm, von, vom Marketing saß eine da. Dann irgendeine,
ähm, Personalabteilungsfrau, das war die mit dem Kopftuch. Ähm, dann saß von, ich glaube,
von der Haustechnik saß einer da. Darf man eigentlich noch, darf, darf man Schwarzer
sagen? People, People of Color heißt der jetzt. Äh, der war von der Haustechnik. Ähm, also
in dem gesamten, in dem gesamten Video über die, über die, über unsere IT-Abteilung
saßen in dem Video vielleicht zwei Leute von 12, 13 da, die wirklich aus der IT-Abteilung
kamen. Das war wirklich so zusammengefakt, wie ich es noch nie gesehen habe, äh. Ich
fand's, der Film ist aber gut, ich kann ihn jetzt nicht zeigen, weil dann wüsste man,
wo ich arbeite, aber, äh, der Film war nicht schlecht am Ende. Also die haben ja handwerklich
verstanden. Ja, und um jetzt halt die, den Bogen zurück zu Ubuntu zu spannen, passt
da jetzt witzigerweise auch dazu. Teile des Films wurden in Südafrika aufgenommen. Äh,
ich weiß, es hört sich jetzt an, als hätt ich mir das ausgedacht, um ne gute Überleitung
zu Ubuntu zu haben, aber das stimmt. Teile des Films wurden in Südafrika aufgenommen.
Nicht, weil irgendwie Südafrika tolle Schauplätze hätte für, für das Video, was so IT-mäßig
aussieht, sondern, weil Südafrika wohl besonders, ähm, besonders gutes Lichtverhältnisse
hat für, frag mich, Dinger. Nein, keine weißen Kinder gezeigt. Die haben, die haben
dort in irgendwelchen Büros Dinge aufgenommen, weil irgendwie das Licht in Südafrika besonders
toll ist. Und haben dann halt so getan, als wär's hier. Obwohl's in Südafrika war. Äh,
aber da sieht man wieder den Unterschied zwischen Realität und was sich gut verkauft und, und
sag mal, zumindest von dem, wo man halt von denkt, es verkauft sich gut und macht sich
gut, ja. Und die Realität ist nicht immer das, was, äh, was gut aussieht. Wir leben
in einer Zeit, wo es halt hip ist, divers zu sein. Es ist da auch überhaupt nichts dagegen
zu sagen, aber es ist halt in dem Fall bei uns nicht die Wahrheit gewesen. Unser Team
ist halt nur wirklich nicht so extrem divers, wenn man's so will. Da ist nicht, das sind
halt zu 90% 20- bis 45-jährige weiße Männer. Es gibt aber immer mehr Mädels in der IT,
muss man sagen. Also es hat die letzten Jahre schon zugenommen, aber vom Verhältnis her
ist es immer noch so, dass es halt, auch bei unseren Azubis, ja, 80% Typen, die anfangen.
Also es scheint schon was dran zu sein, dass sich Männer einfach mehr für Technik interessieren
als Frauen. Hat sich denn nach dem Video was besser verkauft? Das war kein Video, wo
es darum ging, dass wir mehr verkaufen. Das war ein Video, um uns quasi, ähm, image-mäßig,
also auch nicht nach außen hin. Ich glaub, das Video gab es nicht nach außen, sondern
in dieser Konzern- und Partnerstruktur, um uns als besonders gut dastehen zu lassen. Und
das hat anscheinend auch gut funktioniert. Image-Film, ja. In deiner Physik-Klasse ist
kein einziges Mädchen. Wir hatten eins, zwei, drei. Drei hatten wir. Wir hatten drei Stück.
Ich glaub, ich weiß sogar noch, wie die hießen. Aber wir hatten eine Stefanie, wir hatten
eine Jasmin und wir hatten, äh, okay, wie die dritte heißt, keine Ahnung. Wie die dritte
hieß, weiß ich nicht mehr. Aber wir hatten drei Mädels in der Klasse. Und das ist schon
10 Jahre, 13 Jahre her. Wann war denn deine Ausbildung? Ne, 2007. Deswegen sag ich ja
13 Jahre her. Ja, also es gibt immer mehr. Aber anteilmäßig gibt's halt nach wie vor
mehr Männer. Was ich persönlich, da muss man ja aufpassen, was man sagt, ist ja schon
schlimm, aber man muss, ist halt mittlerweile so leider, dass man da aufpassen muss. Ähm,
ich find das aber persönlich auch gar nicht schlimm. Ich bin voll dafür, dass jeder
das machen soll, was er, was er sich wünscht und was er irgendwie gebacken kriegt, was
er machen will, dass man ihm die Chance gibt. Da bin ich vollkommen dafür und es soll wirklich
jeder die Chance bekommen, das zu machen, äh, wo er irgendwie drin aufgeht, ja. Ähm,
aber wenn sich nun mal 80% Männer für technische Berufe entschreien und nur 20% Frauen, ey,
da muss man damit leben. Man kann ja schlecht die Mädels dazu zwingen. Man kann ja schlecht
die Mädels dazu zwingen, ähm, technische Berufe mehr zu ergreifen, äh, auf der Baustelle
zu arbeiten und, und sonst was zu machen, ja. Genauso wenig, wie man Kerle dazu zwingen
kann, ähm, jetzt übermäßig, keine Ahnung, Krankenpfleger, Kindergärtner oder, was
sind da noch, was sind da noch so, so die klassischen Frauenberufe, wo das denen das
so anhaftet, ähm, und sowas in der Richtung zu werden. Muss ja nicht sein. Es soll einfach
schlicht und ergreifend jedem das ermöglicht werden oder sollte jeder die Chance haben,
ähm, das zu machen, was er machen will, aber irgendwelche künstlichen, ähm, äh, wie
heißt, ähm, Quoten und sowas, glaube ich nicht, dass das zielführend ist. Zahnarzthelferin
Müllmann, ja. Ich glaube nicht, dass das, dass das zielführend ist, irgendwelche Quoten
da einzuführen. Weil im Endeffekt, worauf, worauf läuft's denn raus? Wenn man wirklich
verpflichtende Quoten einführt, also sprich, wenn man quasi gar keinen Pool an geeigneten
Bewerbern hat, aber man trotzdem Leute einstellen muss, weil es die Quote vorschreibt, dann
führt das doch eigentlich eher dazu, dass die ganze Sache noch unfairer wird. Weil auf
der einen Seite muss sich dort, wo es genug Leute gibt, müssen sich die Leute abrackern
und wirklich anstrengen, um auf Position, Stelle, was auch immer x, y zu kommen. Und
auf der anderen Seite, wenn es wo es zu wenige gibt, kann man auch einfach nur, weil man
da ist, dann da hinkommen. Das ist doch auch nicht fair. Deswegen bin ich kein Fan von,
von irgendwelchen Quoten. Aber ich bin dafür, dass man jedem ermöglichen sollte, das zu
machen, was er machen will. Und ich finde es gut, dass es immer mal Mädels gibt, die
in technische Berufe gehen. Das ist super. Man sollte das denen auch durchaus schmackhaft
machen, warum nicht, aber irgendwelche Quoten schaffen, finde ich bescheuert. Ja, ich weiß,
dass es, dass das in manchen Bereichen schon solche Ausprägungen leider annimmt. Ist auch,
ist auch eine Sache, ich will mit dem Thema gar nicht zu sehr rumbreiten, da habe ich
mich aber auch schon öfters darüber aufgelassen, dass wir aktuell ein bisschen viel, oder wie
gesagt, dass wir versuchen, also, dass man es extrem vermeidet, irgendwo anzuecken. Also
mal angenommen, ich habe jetzt, keine Ahnung, mir fällt jetzt irgendetwas Blödes ein, ich
poste das auf Twitter. Und ich habe mir da jetzt nicht erst zwei Tage darüber Gedanken
gemacht, dann kann ich sicher sein, dass das irgendjemand anpisst. Und wenn ich groß genug
bin auf Twitter, also richtig groß bin, dann kann auch ein unüberlegter Twitter-Post zu
einem übelsten Shitstorm führen. Ja, manche Sachen sind wirklich dämlich, die gepostet
werden. Bei manchen Sachen ist es auch vollkommen gerechtfertigt, sich da wahnsinnig drüber
aufzuregen, aber man muss mal manchmal ein bisschen die Verhältnismäßigkeit sehen.
Ich habe letztens auf Twitter einen Post gesehen, da hat einer zum Blutspenden aufgerufen.
Da denkt man sich doch jetzt eigentlich, da kann ja nichts Schlimmes dabei sein. Was
kann da ganz Schlimmes dabei sein, wenn einer zu eigentlich einer guten Sache zum Blutspenden
aufruft. Da kann doch, kann man sich doch gar nicht dran stören. Doch, kann man sich
nicht dran stören. Weil, ne nicht wegen Corona, das ist schon ein bisschen, da war noch nicht
Corona, das ist schon, ist schon busy, keine Ahnung, 4-5 Wochen her. Also da war Corona
auch nicht so angesagt. Und da haben sie sich wirklich drüber aufgeregt, weil der ein Bild
gepostet hat, wo man einen Arm gesehen hat von jemanden, der gerade Blutspenden war,
und dem so eine Abzapf, Abzapf Spritze, äh, gesteckt hat. Und da hat da wirklich jemand
drauf geschrieben, ähm, er findet es irgendwie unveran, unverantwortlich, allein schon der,
er findet es irgendwie unverantwortlich, dass man hier einfach, ähm, ähm, quasi Leute
triggert mit spritzten Bildern. Es gibt doch Menschen, die haben, äh, panische Angst
vor Nadeln. Alter, auf was sollst du denn noch alles achten? Auf was sollst du denn
noch alles achten, dass nicht, du kannst es doch gar nicht mehr vermeiden, dass nicht
irgendjemand angepisst ist. Ich mein, es geht ums Blutspenden. Was meint der denn, wie man
das Blut aus dem Arm rauskriegt? Durch, durchsaugen. Also, da passt ne Spritze eigentlich thematisch
ziemlich gut dazu, ja. Und da haben sie sich drüber ereifert und aufgeregt, dass die ne
Spritze gepostet haben. Mitm Messer, ja, super Idee. Wenn du den Typ danach noch zu was gebrauchen
willst am Blutspenden, ist ein Messer glaub ich keine so gute Idee. Ähm, da haben sie
sich ereifert und aufgeregt auf Twitter. Ernsthaft, dass die beim Tweet über Blutspenden ne Spritze
gepostet haben. Da war mir wieder klar, ähm, dass, ich vergesse es manchmal wieder, eigentlich
ist mir sehr klar, dass das heute echt nicht mehr normal ist. Oder was, also das was heute
normal ist, irgendwie nicht bei mir in den Kopf reingeht, sag mal so. Ich find das okay,
wenn man, wenn man, also ich find es sogar gut, wenn man ein bisschen feinfühlig vorgeht
und nicht unbedingt absichtlich Leute anpisst, einfach nur um Leute anzupissen. Ja, das,
da sag ich, das ist, das ist, das ist sogar gut. Man muss nicht unbedingt notgedrungen
Leute aufregen den ganzen Tag, ja. Man gibt genug Trollaccounts. Aber man kann nicht,
es ist unmöglich heute alles zu umschiffen, wo sich irgendjemand angesprochen fühlen
könnte. Das ist, es ist unglaublich mittlerweile in der Richtung. Und vor allem, was ich ja
schlimm, was ich, was ich unter dem Strich daran eigentlich schlimm finde, ähm, gar
nicht mal so sehr, die Leute sind mir da eigentlich wurscht. Die denken mir einfach, manche Leute
kann man nicht, manche Leute kann man nicht helfen. Eine Sache, die ich persönlich, gerade
als jemand, der technisch interessiert ist und ähm, der sich eher für technische Zusammenhänge
interessiert, was ich, was ich persönlich blöd finde, ist, dass dadurch an vielen Stellen
reine, ähm, wie soll man sagen, reine, reine Gefühlslagen vor Inhalt geht. Ich glaub,
das triffts, das triffts eigentlich ganz gut. Also sprich, dass es wichtiger ist, dass
man eventuell den einen von tausend vermeidet, den es anpissen könnte und dann lieber gar
nix zu schreibt oder die Sachen so schwammig und ausgedünnt, dass keiner mehr was mit
anfangen kann. Und das muss eigentlich nicht sein. Ich denke, man kann durchaus mit leben,
wenn man ne Meinung zu nem Thema hat, dass man damit den ein oder anderen vielleicht
findet, der die nicht gut findet. Das, damit müsste doch, müsste man doch eigentlich,
also damit müssten doch alle klarkommen eigentlich. Derjenige, der es sagt und derjenige, der
halt nicht damit einverstanden ist. Naja, gut, aber das ist ja heut nicht so. Ähm,
bei deinem Post zum Thema Klopapier gab es auch ein paar Leute, die entweder am trollen
oder waren oder die hatten andere Probleme. Ey, mein Klopapierpost, da hab ich ja gegen
das verstoßen, was ich gerade gesagt hab, ich hab diesen Post nur gemacht, um Leute
zu ärgern. Weil ich grad gesagt hab, man muss ja nicht unbedingt Post machen, um Leute
zu ärgern. Aber, mein Klopapierpost hab ich nur gemacht, um Leute zu ärgern. Man beachtet
erstens, es ist der 1. April, aber es war kein April-Scherz, muss ich gleich dazu sagen.
Mein Klopapierpost hab ich einzig und allein gemacht, um Leute zu triggern. Allerdings
hat es einen wahren Kern, denn ich bin der, wie sagt man in der Politik so schön, ich
bin der festen, es ist dreilagig, der festen Überzeugung, dass so wie ich das gemanagt
habe mit dem Einkaufen von Klopapier ist für alle Beteiligten das beste ist. Ich hab den
Kram im Internet bestellt vor 14 Tagen. Das heißt, ich habe 14 Tage lang niemand im Supermarkt
Klopapier weggekauft. In Zeiten, wo es eh schon zu wenig im Supermarkt gibt. Ich bin
nicht in einen Supermarkt gegangen, um mir Klopapier zu kaufen, in einer Zeit, wo man
Kontakt zu anderen Menschen vermeiden soll. Also schon mal 2 große Pluspunkte. Dazu kommt,
dass es logistisch einfacher ist, wenn man das im Internet bestellt und einen gewissen
Vorlauf hat. Also da wird nichts irgendwie überladen oder sonst was, da wird halt einfach
verschickt, wenn es da ist. Vergewaltigung trendet in Deutschland, da will ich jetzt gar
nicht mehr draufklicken. Also ich bin der Ansicht, die Art und Weise, wie ich den Kram
bestellt habe und gemanagt habe, das zu bestellen, war für alle Beteiligten das beste. Es gibt
aber genug Leute, die das nicht einsehen wollen. Hier riesig viele Diskussionen drunter, wie
asozial ich bin und es wagen konnte, mir Klopapier zu bestellen. Also ich muss sagen, wie gesagt,
ich habe jetzt seit Anfang Corona in keinem Supermarkt vor Ort Klopapier gekauft. Ich
hatte ein bisschen Vorrat, aber irgendwann ist der auch mal weg. So und ich habe jetzt
so viel gekauft, dass ich einfach auch, ohne jemand im Supermarkt das wegzukaufen wollte,
ich meine, es gibt ja genug Klopapier, es gibt halt vor Ort kein Klopapier, so dass
ich auch die nächsten 5 Monate, 4-5 Monate, niemand im Supermarkt den Kram mehr kaufen
muss. Ich finde, das ist vom Ansatz her das Richtige. Und was mich viel mehr schockiert
hat bei diesem Thema ist, wie unfähig die meisten Leute sind, überhaupt zu verstehen,
dass die Möglichkeit besteht, im Internet Klopapier zu kaufen. Die haben das nicht gecheckt. Dann
haben da Leute gesagt, ja, bei mir, du hast dafür gesorgt, dass es bei mir im Rewe nichts
gibt. Habe ich mir erklärt, warum das nicht der Fall ist, dass ich sogar eher, der kam
auch noch aus Frankfurt, dass ich sogar damit dafür gesorgt habe, dass die Chance, dass
er Klopapier bekommt, höher ist im Rewe als niedriger, weil ich ihm eben nie was weggekauft
habe. Was wollte ich jetzt sagen, genau. Und das war der eine, dass ich darüber aufgeregt
habe, dass er im Rewe nichts mehr gekriegt hat. Und dann gab es andere, die konnten es
nicht nachvollziehen, wie man, ja, natürlich ist es viel, aber das heißt, bei einem Großhändler
bestellt, von dieser Sorte gab es halt nur 96 Rollen. So. Und die anderen haben teilweise
gar nicht verstanden, wie das möglich ist. Der nächste kam an hier unten und hat geschrieben,
ich habe bei Amazon geguckt und bei Amazon gibt es nichts mehr. Was heißt hier online
bestellen oder sowas. Alter, es gibt nicht nur Amazon. Schmeiß halt mal Google an, DuckDuckGo
oder irgendeine Suchmaschine und such nach Klopapier kaufen. Das war für die Leute komplett
Neuland. Die haben es nicht kapiert. Wo ich mir denke, okay, das ist Twitter. Das heißt,
auf Twitter sind eigentlich die etwas technikaffineren, also nicht die ganzen Kacknoobs. Die haben
es nicht kapiert. Das hat mich echt wieder schockiert, ja. Da ist es zwar.
Viele können leider selbst nicht googeln. Das ist so, ja. Das ist leider so. Guck mal,
wir haben null Drop Frames. Heute ist Vodafone nicht so, sondern heute ist Vodafone so. Wieso
stacken alle Klopapier? Ganz ehrlich, was hat das für einen Sinn? Gar keinen. Das hat
überhaupt keinen Sinn, dass man sich so viel Klopapier lagert daheim. Rein nüchtern betrachtet.
Das Problem, was jetzt halt gerade existiert ist, du kriegst vor Ort nichts mehr. Doch,
doch. Zwei Jahre hält das garantiert nicht für zwei Leute. Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Du hast das Problem, dass du vor Ort nichts mehr kriegst gerade. Und im Falle der Fälle,
wenn du keinen großartigen Vorrat hast, also mein Vorrat ist jetzt halt auch mal fertig.
Ich hatte ja noch ein paar Packungen da und jetzt ist es halt nach einem Monat alle gewesen.
Und du kriegst vor Ort nichts mehr. Vor Ort kriegst du aktuell nur noch eine Packung.
Das heißt, du kommst damit gar nicht hin. Weil du brauchst einen gewissen Vorrat. Stell
dir vor, du wirst jetzt wirklich mal krank. Stell dir vor, du kriegst wirklich Corona
und liegst zwei Wochen, drei Wochen daheim. Und du kannst nicht scheißen gehen, weil du
keinen Klopapier hast. Also die einzige Möglichkeit, die es geben würde, wäre, wenn die Leute
nicht so bescheuert wären und den Supermarkt leer kaufen würden und jeder könnte sich
einfach im Supermarkt normalen Tagesbedarf holen. Oder normalen Tagesbedarf plus Vorrat.
Das wäre für alle Beteiligten das Beste. Also man könnte einfach in den Supermarkt
und sich, ich sag jetzt einfach, vier Packungen holen und da hat man erstmal genug. Das wäre
für alle Beteiligten das Beste. Ist es aber, ist es aber nicht. Hast du nicht sowieso dein
japanisches Klo? Doch, hab ich. Das ist aber kein japanisches Klo. Das ist ein Geberit
Aquaclean 8500 plus. Oder? Oder? 8000 plus. Nicht 8500 plus. Exzellent. 8500 plus. Ja.
So siehts aus. Leute, es ist 22.25 Uhr. So langsam, aber sicher muss ich mal ins Bett.
Ich bin müde. Residenz Sleeper. Oh, der Hacker. Neuer Hacker. Denks läuft der immer noch.
Äh. Äh. Möchte sich das nicht beenden vielleicht? Was ist da los? MonkaS
Smoke. Wo hab ich denn mein Smoke? Mein Smoke Emote. Ah, jetzt, jetzt. Weiß gar nicht
warum ich das suspended hab. Ja, der andere kann das suspended. Dein Klo hat Raytracing.
RTX on Klo. Ja, das muss sein. Kann man 2020 schon mal haben, find ich. Okay. Also Nudel,
Nudelvorräte hab ich tatsächlich genug. Ich hab's ja schon mal erzählt. Ich hab'
ne Schrank oder fast, fast nen Schrank voller Nudel. Den hab ich aber immer. Weder aus
irgendwelchen Corona-Kunden noch irgendwie, weil ich der Hardcore-Prepper bin oder so,
sondern weil der Kram hält. Dann reicht's, wenn man einmal ordentlich einkauft und dann
hat man erstmal Nudel. Eats. So Leute, Fazit für heute. Wie war der Sound? Besser, schlechter,
kein Unterschied gehört. Besser, gut. Null, jetzt geht der Chat, ich raste aus. OMG,
wie der Chat geht. Ungewöhnlich nice, okay. Ja, dann würd ich sagen, lass ich das doch
mal so mit den Audio-Settings. Klingt älter als sonst. Naja, vielleicht bin ich jetzt
ja auch älter als sonst. Ihr wisst ja nicht, wann ich Geburtstag hab. Warum kein ZFS mehr
auf der Arbeit? Äh, weil wir keinen Anwendungszweck mehr so wirklich für haben. Das Einzige, wo
wir riesengroße Sto- Also, was ist riesengroße? Das Einzige, wo wir richtig viel Storage am
Stück haben, ist für die Oracle Datenbank Zeug. Aber ansonsten haben wir wenig große
Storage Sachen. Wir haben da keinen Anwendungszweck für. Vielleicht für unsere Mail-Backups,
da wäre das noch eine Option, aber das funktioniert anders. Ja, deswegen haben wir kein ZFS auf
der Arbeit. Wir haben da irgendwie nicht den Anwendungszweck für. Und was man auch dazu
sagen muss, wir haben keine wahnsinnig guten ZFS-Pros. Ich mein, ich kenn mich, so die
grundlegenden Admin-Sachen kenne ich mich mit ZFS aus. Aber ich würd sagen, ich bin
weit davon entfernt, wahnsinnig gut mit ZFS auszukennen. ZFS und Performance nicht zwangsläufig.
ZFS ist nicht unbedingt schneller als ein normales Datensystem. Ich würd sogar sagen,
durch das alles, was drumherum passiert, ist sogar rein IO-technisch und Zugriffszeiten-technisch
und IO, auf den Plan würd ich sogar sagen, ist ZFS ein Ticken langsamer sogar als andere
Datensysteme. Dafür hast du halt die ganzen Vorteile von ZFS. Was ZFS halt sehr schnell
macht, ist, dass es erstmal die Sachen in RAM packt und dass man eventuell nach SSD-Caches
verwenden kann. Aber wenn man das mal außen vor lässt, würd ich sogar sagen, durch den
ganzen Kram, den ZFS zusätzlich macht, ist ZFS sogar ein Ticken langsamer als so ein
normales Fallsystem. Cluster-FS. Nee, haben wir auch nicht. Wir haben ZEF. ZEF-FS. ZEFs.
Das tut wunderbar. Es ist jetzt aber nicht so das Performance-Wunder, aber es ist groß.
Leute, mal gucken, ob wir uns morgen sehen. Spätestens Sonntag sehen wir uns. Schlaf
gut, wir sehen uns. Bis spätestens Sonntag, macht's gut. CU.